So.
Och, der Hammer.
Alter.
Ist ja wie in alten Zeiten hier.
Ach, ist nicht schön.
Wie früher.
Weißt du noch, Kilian, früher?
Früher.
Als wir uns getroffen haben.
Das böse F-Wort.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ist der vom...
Weißt du, dass wir diesen Podcast jetzt schon fast fünf Jahre machen?
Was?
Aber warte, ist da die Covid-Sandard-Time mit eingerechnet?
Ne, Corona-Zeit zählt.
Heute ist der 424. März 2020.
Finde ich gut.
März kann nie genug Tage haben.
Ich glaube, das waren auch bei One-Eror.
Ich glaube, da habe ich schon mal nachgerechnet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie es gefixt haben.
Nach dem Ausbruch, in welchem Land wird das gerechnet?
Ich glaube, das ist einfach seit dem 1. März gerechnet.
Also dann immer weiter.
Der März hat halt nie aufgehört.
Da gab es so einen Song von Green Day.
Wake me up when March ends.
Nee, wake me up when Corona ends.
Das könnte man sogar machen.
Nicht schlecht.
Ja, also wir haben uns jetzt eine Weile nicht unterhalten.
Die alte Älterefolge ist ja gar nicht so lange her, oder?
Nee, aber irgendwie geht das auch so.
Das muss eigentlich, also bei mir setzt so ein bisschen Corona-Fatige ein insofern, als dass einfach, ich weiß nicht, Depression ist es nicht, aber es ist einfach nichts los, du machst nichts, du hast wenig Inspiration.
Ich unterhalte mich relativ wenig mit Leuten allgemein.
Ich rufe meine Eltern an.
Ja.
Eltern müssen bei dir anrufen, in der Normalität.
Ja, das ist komisch.
Nee, nichts gegen Eltern. Eltern kann man auch mal anrufen.
Eltern kann man auch mal anrufen.
Aber trotzdem, ich verstehe, was du meinst.
Das ist ein bisschen, die Realität fühlt sich anders an aktuell.
Und was mir halt für den Podcast fehlt,
ist, dass so ein bisschen die Inspiration abhandengekommen ist,
weil auch andere Gespräche, die ich so weiß nicht,
mit Kollegen kommst du einfach nicht mehr vom Hundertsten ins Tausendste
und quatscht.
weil ich rede nur noch über Arbeit mit Leuten.
Kennst du das?
Ja, das zackt so ein bisschen.
Schönen Gruß vom Steiger übrigens.
Den habe ich an der Elbe getroffen gestern.
Krass, habe ich ewig nicht mehr gesehen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Boah, so ein Glück ist locker zwei Coronas her.
Ach bitte, sag sowas nicht.
Was machst du so zur Zeit?
Hast du irgendwelche Corona-Hobbys?
Ich habe mir kürzlich eine Ukulele zugelegt.
Echt jetzt?
Ich kann noch nicht Ukulele.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, da drüben liegt eine.
Kannst du dir das schon mal zeigen?
Ich werde demnächst irgendwann mal unser Intro probieren
hinzukriegen. Das dauert bestimmt noch
so drei, vier Folgen, also in drei Jahren bin ich bereit.
Welche Stimmung hast du?
Was?
Wie ist deine Ukulele gestimmt?
So wie meine Ukulele stimmt?
Da gibt es zwei Schulen.
Oh, ich kenne nur die eine. Ich glaube, das geht C A E.
Ah ja, genau. Und es gibt noch die
ADFIS H.
Aus irgendeinem Grund
hat mir das ein bekannter,
gemeinsamer bekannter Betreiber eines Matrix-Servers.
Irgendwann haben wir mal über Ukulele geredet und gesagt,
ja, Stimmung ist ADFIS-H, auch
du fistest Huren.
Das ist seitdem bei mir, der hat dich eingebrannt,
dieser Spruch.
Das ist definitiv ein guter Merkspruch,
den werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr verlieren.
Und dann habe ich dummerweise die Akkorde auf
der Stimmung gelernt und die
sind aber subtil
in der Minderheit
von den Ukulelen. Was heißt das, wenn ich nur
normale Ukulele von jemand anderem in die Hand nehme,
dann spiele ich die falschen Akkorde da drauf.
Okay, ich wusste nicht, dass das so
ein Ding ist. Aber es ist bloß ein Tonunterschied,
das geht theoretisch. Okay, spannend.
Das ist aber ein tolles Instrument. Macht noch Spaß. Ich habe vorher
noch nie ein Seiteninstrument gespielt.
Was hast du noch vorher gespielt? Ich habe
boah, das ist aber schon wieder eine Weile her.
Ich habe in der Schule mal Klarinette
gelernt und nachdem ich gemerkt habe,
wie uncool es ist, Klarinette zu spielen, habe ich
nach zwei Jahren umgestiegen und habe
Altsax gespielt für bestimmt
15 Jahre, 10 Jahre, 15 Jahre.
Echt? Nee, so lange auch nicht.
Das kann nicht sein. Sagen wir mal 10 Jahre, 10 Jahre
ungefähr hin. Wir müssen uns mal zum Jam treffen.
Ich habe es aber schon seit locker auch zehn Jahren nicht mehr angefasst.
Das ist zum Beispiel so ein Corona-Hobby, was weniger geht, weil man sich irgendwie nicht traut.
Also ich traue mich nicht, Leute zu besuchen oder Leute so doll zu besuchen zu haben.
Vor allem so ein Blasinstrument, das unpraktischste Instrument, was du zu Corona-Zeiten spielen kannst.
Das hier, das Tanzorchester Ehrenfeld, wo die Blasabteilung in einen anderen Raum verbannt.
Hast du das schon mal gesehen?
Vom Böhmermann, vom ZDF-Magazin Neo.
Die waren extra super stolz, dass sie jetzt
diese neue Band haben.
Und auf der Bühne siehst du aber nur
alle, außer die Bläser.
Und dann schneiden sie ab und zu mal in den anderen Raum,
der komplett anders beleuchtet ist, wo so fünf, sechs Bläser stehen.
Die stehen in so einer Art Duschkabinen einzeln,
wo überall nochmal Glas drumherum ist.
Das sieht sehr lustig aus.
Ich frage mich, ob sie das wirklich live spielen oder zusammenschneiden.
Kriegt man sowas live hin?
Kriegst du so latenzfreie Übertragungen auch nur auf ein paar Meter hin,
dass man da ordentlich was spielen kann?
Ja, auf jeden Fall, wenn du einen
analogen Anschluss hast, definitiv.
Wenn du so ein Studio hast, ein Tonstudio
oder sowas hast, ist es häufig, dass du
die Leute in mehreren Räumen
hintereinander hast. Da hast du so einen Mischpultraum,
wo du durch so eine
Glasscheibe durch in den nächsten Raum guckst,
wo meistens die Sänger stehen
oder die Sänger haben manchmal noch so einen eigenen Raum,
wo die von solchen Eierpappen umgeben sind,
damit der Raum schön trocken klingt.
Und dann kannst du manchmal, also hinter dem
ersten Raum, in den du reinguckst, wo jemand spielt,
ist dann meistens noch der nächste Raum, wo dann eventuell, was du siehst, der Schlagzeuger steht.
Witziger, weil man trennt die Spuren tatsächlich auch physisch voneinander.
Ja, definitiv. Das ist hauptsächlich, damit du den einen nicht auf der Spur von der anderen mit drauf hast
und damit auch der Raum nicht mit drin ist.
Okay, ich dachte immer, wenn man schon eine Aufnahme zusammen macht als Gruppe, als Band, was auch immer,
dass man die Leute auch dann in den einen Raum zusammensperrt oder man nimmt die Sachen einzeln auf,
obwohl es dann wahrscheinlich timingmäßig ein bisschen schwierig sein könnte.
Man nimmt häufig die Sachen zusammen, also man nimmt die Sachen einzeln auf, sie spielen sie aber häufig zusammen,
dass du einfach, wenn du dich schlagst durch eine Gitarre
oder schlagst durch einen Bass spielen,
irgendwie eine Stuhl zusammen und dann kommt der
Sänger erst später dazu oder sowas.
Okay, witzig war ich, ich hatte keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, ich war mal in einem Tonstudio,
weil eine Schulfreundin
hat Tonmeister gelernt.
Und die haben mal in einem Tonstudio aufgenommen.
Stimmt, wir waren mal
in einem Tonstudio und da weißt du ja auch, dass da irgendwie
diese Glaswand...
Und manchmal hast du halt noch einen Raum dahinter,
wo du so durch zwei Glasscheinen durchgucken kannst.
Und dann siehst du manchmal
Meta, da gehen halt genauso wie Stromleitung
oder Ethernet-Kabel durch die
Wohnung, gehen da halt so
XLR-Kabel, wie ich das hier an den Dings habe,
durch die Gegend.
Und dann hast du so riesen
Patch-Schränke, die
aussehen wie so ein Server-Schrank, bloß dass
die Leute da XLR-Kabel aneinander patchen, ist
total lustig.
Auf jeden Fall. Nee, Turnstudio ist auf jeden Fall schön.
Wie kommen wir jetzt auf sowas?
Du hast nach Corona-Hobbys gefragt.
Was übrigens in der Zeit aktuell?
Ja, ich backe Brot und ich koche.
Sauerteig angesetzt.
Nee, nee, tatsächlich.
Brot backe ich überhaupt nicht.
Ein Projekt, was ich hatte,
ich gehe spazieren.
Und ich hatte neulich mal gepostet,
hier, das hier musste ich leider alles wegschmeißen.
Ich habe mir bei Stadtgärtner
habe ich mir Saatbomben bestellt.
Ach, das war das mit dem Wegschmeißen.
Ich war erst irritiert, dass du das geschrieben hast.
Was ist das? Irgendwas Essbares?
Ist das schlecht geworden?
Genau, das gibt es irgendwie bei
stadtgärtner.de
das eigentlich ziemlich cool,
habe ich die Seite hier offen, genau,
die stadtgärtner.de
kannst du so Pakete bestellen
und das sind dann solche kleinen, wie schwarze
Pingpongbälle sehen die aus
und die kannst du dann irgendwo hinwerfen,
wo du denkst, da müssten mehr Pflanzen,
mehr bunte Blumen wachsen.
Da gibt es dann so die Abteilung,
wie heißen die hier alle?
Wir waren ja kürzlich mal eine Runde
spazieren, da hattest du welche dabei und die haben wir dann
auf der Wiese versenkt gehabt.
Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt.
Sieht bestimmt viel schöner aus jetzt demnächst, diese Wiese.
Ja, es ist noch nicht so richtig losgegangen.
Ich gehe da jetzt immer mal dran vorbei.
Es ist ja schon zwei oder drei Wochen her, dass ich da wirklich was
hingeschmissen habe, aber seitdem habe ich noch nichts gesehen.
Aber die Kategorien sind lustig.
Es gibt Bienenschmaus.
Sehr schön.
Und Bienenwohl.
Das ist irgendwie nicht das Gleiche.
Und
dann gibt es Wilde Wiese
oder
Let it be.
Bienenweide
gibt es auch noch.
Und dann gibt es
blühendes Kornfeld. Ich weiß nicht,
das steht nicht so genau. Und Sonnenblumen
gibt es. Das kann ich mir darunter vorstellen,
was damit gemeint ist. Genau.
Und da habe ich auf irgendeiner Wiese hier in Dresden...
Gummistiefel sind meine Pumps.
Weiß wir wieder nicht, was das sein soll.
Na, na, sind meine Pumps.
Ja, den Titel
besteh ich schon, aber ich weiß nicht, was da an Pflanzen
dahinter steht. Achso, stimmt.
Tja, das ist, das
liest sich ein bisschen wie so ein T, ne?
Ja, T-Namen sind auch so ein Ding.
T-Namen, Verführende Namen und anscheinend auch Seedbomben
Namen. Und so sehr beschreibend.
Und Spotify Playlisten.
So eine Lo-Fi Seedbomb.
Das ist Lo-Fi Seedbomb.
Ja, genau, das kannst du, das wird's garantiert auf YouTube.
Lo-Fi Seedbomb.
Das ist eigentlich so ein Spiel, das hat
nie, das könnten wir noch mal
machen irgendwann.
Guess if it's a T or a
zumindest, jetzt können wir raten,
ist es ein Badezusatz oder ist es eine
Spotify-Playlist?
Das finde ich auch gut.
Ist es ein Badezusatz oder eine Spotify-Playlist?
Zumindest habe ich auf dieser Wiese irgendwie
Saatbombenwert von 60 Euro versenkt
und ich bin seitdem immer mal dran vorbeigegangen
und ich habe seitdem noch nicht wieder was gesehen.
Entweder ist es in irgendeinem Frost, der dann im April
nochmal kam, gestorben.
Ach Quatsch, also nee, das kommt schon noch durch,
das braucht noch ein paar Tage.
Das ist übrigens akronomisierbar Folge 48.
Krass, so ein allbekannter
Tech-Podcast. Ich habe übrigens letztens
einer Freundin erzählt
davon, dass wir einen Podcast machen.
Ein Tech-Podcast. Das war so ein bisschen außer Kontext.
Und sie hat mich dann ein paar Momente später gefragt,
ob wir über Tekken oder über Techno-Musik
sprechen.
Ich habe erst gemerkt, dass der Kontext völlig fehlte,
leider.
Fand ich aber cool.
Wie sollte man einen Podcast über Tekken machen, über das Spiel
Tekken? Dann ein bisschen Techno-Musik
einspielen und dann bist du plötzlich nach dem Visierbaut.
Welches Spiel ist denn das?
Ich kann ehrlich gesagt Tekken,
Mortal Kombat und Street Fighter nicht auseinanderhalten.
Ich hab hier alle drei nie wirklich viel gespielt.
Ich hab alle mal irgendwo sicherlich
in meiner Jugend mal kurz gespielt gehabt,
aber das ist ein Blob als dasselbe Spiel.
Aber du kannst bei allen irgendwie
A, A, B, B, Left, Right, Left, Right.
Der Konami-Code, so wie auf meiner Seite.
Gibt's das noch?
Klar. Auf Kian, I.O. einfach den Konami-Code
abgeben. Ab, Ab, Down, Down, Left, Right, Left, Right,
B, A.
Moment.
Vorher Lautsprecher anmachen. Immer Lautsprecher anmachen.
Kian, Funk, I.O.
Das nehme ich ja.
Up, up, down, down, left, right, left, right,
AB? Nein.
Ja, try again.
Den Fall habe ich auch gehandelt.
Up, down, up, down.
Nein, up, up, down, down.
Up, up, down, down, left, right, left, right, BA.
Müssen wir da jetzt eigentlich Royalties bezahlen,
wenn das auf dem Band ist?
Mach mal zu.
Aber sehr schöne Animationen.
Das hast du sehr liebevoll gemacht.
Sehr, sehr, sehr liebevoll.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, die Font hat sich auch zu Comic Sans geändert gehabt.
Und die Schriftgröße war, glaube ich, dann
ein bisschen variabel.
Comic Sans ist doch schön.
Da fällt mir was ein. Kennst du Code Sans?
Code Sans? Nee.
Code Sans. Das habe ich tatsächlich eine Zeit lang benutzt.
Das ist eine Schrift, die keinen Code zulässt, weil Sans Code.
Nee, das ist Comic Sans
als Monospace.
Monocomic.
Ja.
Das ist, glaube ich,
Ich muss den Link mal raussuchen.
Ich habe das mal tatsächlich installiert.
Also ich kann ja einfach bei meiner Suche
noch
Font mit eingeben.
Google Fonts,
Code Font, Coding Font,
nevermind.
Comic Sans Code.
Oder heißt die Comic Code?
Comic Code?
Comic Code!
Comic Code heißt die Font.
Sieht aus wie Comic Sans, bloß du kannst damit tippen.
Ich habe Comic-Schanz gefunden.
Das ist, glaube ich, dieselbe Idee.
Are you the kind of person that uses Comic Sans in presentations?
Do you lie awake every night dreaming about a world where you could write your code in Comic Sans,
where it looks just as beautiful as on your dear presentations?
Wait no more!
I present to you Comic Sans, the Comic Sans-inspired monospace,
that font that's coming to a terminal or editor near you.
Es sieht tatsächlich
nicht terrible aus.
Ich meine, schau mal, das hier ist ein
Bueschot aus, wie es Code.
Ich finde das, also für den Code Explorer würde es jetzt nicht nehmen,
aber dein Code hier auf der rechten Seite da.
Das ist eigentlich super nice.
Es ist ein bisschen angenehmer für die Augen,
muss ich sagen.
Das moderne Comic Sans ist doch,
ah, vielleicht heißt das Comic
Sans, weil die Person
Shan-Persent heißt,
die Shan-Persent. Ah, ich habe das verstanden.
Cool.
Das moderne Comic Sans ist doch eigentlich diese Font,
die die ganzen Android-User als System-Font setzen,
die so ein bisschen schnörkelig ist.
Die eigentlich gefühlt so alle Teens mit einem Android-Gerät
mal drin haben für ein paar Jahre.
Und mein 50-jähriger Nachbar, wie ich vorhin mal da gemerkt habe.
Ja, manchmal geht es halt auch echt nicht weg.
Ich habe heute gehört, Microsoft...
Ich werde dich auch nicht schämen dafür, ich finde das cool.
Microsoft hat jetzt irgendwie so eine Aktion draußen,
die suchen nach einer neuen oder die wählen gerade irgendwie,
nachdem sie 15 Jahre Calibri als Hauptsystemschriftart gehabt haben.
Heißt Calibri nicht gerade erst eingeführt worden?
Das ist schon 15 Jahre her.
Ja, von mir aus hatten es auch
in der letzten Version erst überall
Times New Roman stehen, aber
jetzt haben sie irgendwie ein Angebot und die
suchen irgendwie eine aus diesen
fünf. Bierstadt.
Die heißt Bierstadt.
Bierstadt. Ich stehe dir vor,
die Hauptstadt, die Hauptstadt,
die Hauptfond, die Defaultfond
von Microsoft könnte Bierstadt
sein. Bierstadt, schön.
Die Default-Font,
den MS World, hat doch eine
unglaubliche Tragweite. Die findest du
gefühlt auf allem, was auch immer das ist. Sei das Times New Roman,
sei das Calibri. Das erkennst du auch sofort?
Nach anscheinend 15 Jahren.
Ich muss sagen, ich hatte mir Calibri
teilweise selber als...
Das finde ich auch super schick. Das ist eine angenehme Font.
Ach nee, warte mal.
Auf Genome hieß die
Default-Font so ähnlich wie Calibri
Anyway. Wir reden hier über Sachen, die sich kein Mensch
anhören kann.
Nee, aber Bierstadt.
Gierstadt.
Es hat ja so was, es hat ja so ein,
irgendwie ist es in der Font-Designer-Szene,
ist es irgendwie so ein Ding, dass halt
das Fonts einen deutschen
Namen hat.
Nein, nicht einen germanischen, aber häufig
hast du so Font-Designs, wo dann einfach
eine Variation davon heißt
Neue. Weil irgendwann mal
jemand eine Schriftart irgendwie benannt
hat und dann stand da die neue Variation.
Aber ich glaube, das ist eher so das Gefühl, dass
man orientiert dann eher mit ins
Schweizerdeutsche oder in die Schweiz
geografisch mit rein. Wegen dem Helvetia?
Würde ich jetzt grob sagen,
dass das eher so ein Ding ist, dass man sich
so ein cooler Designer mit so einer
Hipsterbrille fühlt sich eher als Schweizer
statt als Deutscher, wenn der Neue schreibt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie der
Schweizer
fahren eher so diese
Fixie-Räder.
Ja?
Quatsch.
Gerade dieses Bild im Kopf.
Das ist ein komisches Bild von Schweizer. Ich glaube, wir müssen uns mal mit
einen Schweizer unterhalten,
was so ein Schweizer
so
von sich hält, wenn er sein Fixie fährt
und seine Helvizia-Schrift schreibt.
Verwandtschaft in der Schweiz,
man kann die mal einladen.
Witzig, nee, Bierstadt finde ich cool.
Grandview als zweiten Vorschlag finde ich auch sehr schön.
Ich habe lange Jahre,
ein paar Jahre.
Seaford könnte ich mir noch vorstellen,
aber hier, Skina,
das geht doch eigentlich nicht, oder?
Termorite klingt auch wieder cool.
Aber Bierstadt ist natürlich der logische Sieger.
Ich hoffe, sie lassen das Internet abstimmen.
Dann kommt
Fonti, Mac,
Fontface.
Es gibt vielleicht.
Fonti, Mac, Fontface.
Fonti, Mac.
Meine Lieblingsschriftart habe ich hier auf
hoodie.de jahrelang als
Standardschriftart, hauptsächlich in
Überschriften, ist Vollkorn.
Vollkorn.
Diese klassischen deutschsprachigen
Fontnamen, sowie auch
eine Schriftart, die du sehr häufig siehst,
wenn du sie einmal erkannt hast, siehst,
dann siehst du die immer wieder,
ist Kaffeesatz. Ist das wie so dieser
Bader-Meinhof-Effekt, wenn du es einmal gehört hast,
einmal gesehen hast, dann siehst du sie immer wieder.
Oh, doch, die kann man bekannt vor. Ja, ja, ohne Kaffeesatz.
Wenn du die einmal, also
gerade wenn du dir dieses, ich glaube, hier ist
es schwer zu erkennen, aber wenn du mal ein kleines
K in Kaffeesatz gesehen hast,
dann kriegst du das nie wieder
aus dem Kopf. Warte mal, ein kleines
K. Das ist wirklich der beste Podcast,
zum anderen. Aha, also ein abgerundeter
wie so ein kleines R,
so mit einem langen Seitenreifen. Dann lass uns mal über eines
unserer normalen Themen reden. Ein großes R
bloß mit einem langen vorderen Balken
und einem kleiner. Wir wollen
die letzten Zuhörer auch noch loswerden.
Wir hatten auch coole Themenvorschläge, ehrlich
gesagt, in unserem akronomisierbaren Matrix-Channel.
Schönen Gruß an die Leute in unserem akronomisierbaren
Matrix-Channel. Restlos alle
unserer Hörer.
Genau, und da sind ein paar schöne Themen dabei gewesen.
Und
wir waren aber zu langsam, Köln, wir waren zu langsam.
Die Analyse von der Pass-for-all-App ist in unserem Channel losgetreten worden.
Und dann hat das Penta-Radio uns die Folge weggeschnappt.
Schlimm, schlimm, dass sowas passiert.
Aber wir haben ja jetzt hier letztens erst mal den Vorschlag bekommen,
Rust im Linux-Kernel wieder anzuschauen.
Und hast du es gemacht?
Da haben wir beide keine Ahnung von.
Also ich weder von Rust noch vom Linux-Kernel.
Du weder viel von Rust, aber du meinst es auch nicht so vom Linux-Kernel.
Also zumindest was die Kombination angeht.
Wir könnten einen von den Leuten, die uns da vorgeschlagen wurden,
echt mal einladen dazu.
Das Thema ist ja wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile aktuell, oder?
Bestimmt.
Meinst du, dass du im Linux-Körnel nächste Woche schon wieder nicht mehr geil bist?
Apropos Linux-Körnel.
Hast du diese
Forscher, in Anführungsstrichen,
diese amerikanische Uni mitbekommen,
die komplett gestrichen wurde,
die nicht mehr Patches hat mit dürfen
für den Linux-Körnel?
Michigan, oder?
Michigan war das, ja, ich glaube auch.
Was für Arschlecher sind das denn mit?
Das war
eine legitime Sicherheitsanalyse.
Kriegen für Shardcode untergebracht.
Also, was ist passiert? Genau, kurze Backstory dazu.
Anscheinend wollten
die ein Paper dazu schreiben,
wie einfach es ist, oder eine Studie fahren,
keine Ahnung, aber die haben danach ein Paper dazu geschrieben,
wie einfach es ist, Shardcode
oder, nicht Shardcode,
schlechten Code, von Bugs
zersetzten Code, in den Linux-Körnern zu kriegen,
wenn man, was war das noch?
Noch Bullshit-Commit-Message
dazu schreibt oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Und haben da halt Kram
submitted gehabt, Patches submitted
haben, da wurden auch schon Dinge reingemürzt und später
kam das halt raus, was
Minnesota war es. Okay, sorry Michigan.
Michigan ist
auch sehr viel in der Presse in letzter Zeit.
Aber hauptsächlich, weil da die Polizisten
haben wie alle möglichen Leute erschießen.
Nee, ähm,
und haben halt da auch Dinge reingemürzt bekommen
und später ist es halt rausgekommen und dann musste
der ganze Scheiß im Nachhinein wieder rausgepatcht werden.
Einfach nur, weil das halt nicht okay ist, wenn
unter der Annahme, dass schon die
Patches ermittet wurden, dass sie da
Schrott unterbringen wollten, wo wahrscheinlich
Bugs drin, wo die nicht nur wahrscheinlich Bugs drin sind,
wo offensichtlich Bugs drin sind.
Also die haben nicht einfach bloß hier
den Pull-Request aufgemacht und
als er dann acceptiert wurde, haben sie gesagt, haha,
sondern das wurde wirklich gemercht.
Ein paar Changes waren schon
drin und das kam halt später noch mehr dazu. Und da ist es halt
dann eben aufgekommen, warum sie das
gemacht haben. Und da haben sich halt,
ich weiß nicht, wie der Typ heißt, dieser eine Maintener
vom News-Könnel, der hat sich halt auf der Mail-Investe
herrlich darüber echauffiert, dass das halt überhaupt
nicht geht und was soll die Scheiße, sucht euch ein anderes
Projekt, wenn ihr einfach nur...
schaden wollt, wir sind nicht dafür da,
von euch hier einfach nur den Chartcode zu mergen,
zu reviewen und da rein zu mergen
potenziell auch. Das ist einfach nur
verschwendet jetzt Lebenszeit und
ekelhaft. Und finde ich auch völlig legitim, dass
die dann erstmal sagen, nee, von euch können wir jetzt gar nichts mehr annehmen,
habt ihr jetzt alle verkackt. Natürlich schön, dass ich,
du hast so ein Statement offen gerade hier.
Ich finde es schön, dass der Typ, der sich dafür entschuldigt,
Heimdahl mit Nachnamen heißt, der hat das offenbar nicht gesehen,
dass das passiert ist. Ja, nicht
wie sein Opa wahrscheinlich, der
den Bifrost aufgemacht hat.
Ja, aber was ist denn, wenn er jetzt,
Wenn du jetzt tatsächlich Student an der Uni bist und dann bist du mit dem Patch und du hast leider dummerweise, so wie wir das hatten, so eine TU Dresden E-Mail-Adresse, haben die dann irgendwie so eine CS and Engineering Minnesota E-Mail-Adresse?
Also das...
Punkt.
Bei der Minnesota Uni auf jeden Fall, sicherlich.
Ist natürlich aktuell ein bisschen blöd, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sie, die Uni
entschuldigt, hat sich ja anscheinend entschuldigt und hat das Projekt irgendwie gestrichen und
wahrscheinlich da intern ein paar nette Gespräche geführt.
Ist natürlich richtig scheiße von den Leuten, die diese Absicht auch tatsächlich hatten,
die das halt, die auf diese Idee kamen, das zu machen, das einfach nur...
Wir nehmen jetzt Entschuldigung übrigens sehr gerne Spenden für den Linux-Körnel entgegen.
Nee, aber wie kommt man auf so eine Assi-Idee?
Das ist einfach voll daneben.
sowas zu machen.
Ja, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das
irgendwie für diese,
wissenschaftlich oder so als Analyse
ist das durchaus interessant zu sagen,
mal gucken,
es ist ja nicht so, dass man,
die meisten Analysen, was Sicherheit
angeht, sind ja häufig darauf aus,
irgendwie statische Analyse zu machen oder
zu schauen,
wie findet man nachträglich
heraus, ob der Code gut ist oder nicht,
aber tatsächlich diesen Social Engineering Aspekt
auszuprobieren, ist eigentlich ein interessantes
Thema, aber ich würde dann tatsächlich
erwarten, dass er es nicht so weit kommen lassen,
dass der Code tatsächlich gemerged wird.
Ja, und denkst du wirklich, du stehst
im Nachhinein da als der coole Forscher
da? Ich hätte viel zu viel Schiss,
dass ich irgendwie dann nur Hate
abbekomme von literally allen,
wenn das irgendwie ein bisschen breiter bekannt ist.
Wieso, wenn er einen Vortrag, ich könnte mir
einen Vortrag auf dem Kongress
vorstellen, wo einer sagt, wir haben mal
geschaut, Open Source Projekte, man sagt ja immer
Open Source ist sicher und
viele Leute gucken drauf. Also haben wir mal
offensichtlich kaputten Code an 100
Open Source Projekte versucht zu
zu main...
Sobald du dir nach... gleich wieder informierst.
Ja, wie du schon sagst, wahrscheinlich wieder was anderes.
Und Responsible Disclosure
und dann natürlich dafür sorgen,
dass der Code nicht wirklich irgendwann
mal irgendwo ausgerollt wird.
Definitiv. Ich hätte trotzdem über den Talk
geschaut, wenn jemand sich bei PC Wahl beworben
hat und da Schadkord
reinkriegen.
Ich habe jetzt zehn Jahre
bei PC-Wahl gearbeitet.
Hast du diesen
Maulwurf-Film geguckt?
Den Maulwurf-Film?
Den Typen, der sich für die
Freunde Koreas... Achso, ja, ja,
diese ZDF-Dug, die war...
Muss man mal gucken,
ob die noch in der Mediathik ist.
Der Maulwurf, ja. Das war
ein bisschen krass. Also das fängt ja noch so
so Low-Level an, hier Typ will
irgendwie sich komisch gutstellen mit
Korea, um da ein paar Infos
zu sammeln. Und am Ende geht es halt
so weit, dass sie halt eine
Waffenfabrik, eine unterirdische
Waffenfabrik auf einer Insel bauen
wollen. Hatten sie eigentlich diese Insel
schon evakuiert oder nicht?
Da waren sie ja dann dabei.
Das war einfach so
völlig absurd. Das klang wie so ein Evil Genius Film.
Auf jeden Fall.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken. Normalerweise stehen hier auf den
Mediatheken, bis wann man den noch gucken kann,
verfügbar bis 31.
März 2024.
Also sucht mal den,
wir packen das in die Show Notes.
Das ist aber Teil 2 hier.
Ja, genau. Ich paste es trotzdem hier schon rein.
Ja, das kriegen wir mal.
Oh Mann.
Das war echt witzig.
Auf jeden Fall.
So, du arbeitest jetzt offiziell in einem Matrix-Klärchen.
Wir werden dann ja aber durch die Themen durch.
Ja, ich habe offiziell meinen Job gekündigt.
Ja, Kilian, was gibt es denn sonst noch so bei dir Neues?
Das wird niemals gar nicht gewesen.
Übrigens, apropos Nordkorea.
Hast recht, wir können ein bisschen mal das Tempo rausnehmen.
Das lässt du aber alles so drin.
Das sind so die Corona-Hobbys,
Dokus gucken,
obwohl gar nicht so viele Dokus gucken.
Ich hab eine coole Serie letztens geschaut.
Disney plus irgendwie die kleine Millionfrau gucken.
Alles Disney plus durchgeschaut,
durchgespielt.
Nein, aber hier natürlich
die Marvel-Serien
super gut.
Sag mal nichts über Falcon und Dings,
weil das habe ich noch nicht geschaut.
Ist immer super schwierig, weil
dummerweise ist mein, ich gucke auch relativ viel
YouTube und mein YouTube-Feed ist dann voll
bereits mit Sachen.
Ich meine, dadurch, dass das Zeug halt auch populär ist
und der Algorithmus halt merkt, dass du das hin und
wieder vor dem Täter so MCU-Content anklickst,
ist natürlich dann direkt deine
Timeline vollgespült von sowas.
Hast du sowas wie Nebula
oder sowas abonniert? Nebula.
Nebula, das ist so ein,
machen regelrecht eine YouTuber-Werbung
für einen anderen Streaming-Dienst, wo sie
fast die gleichen Videos, bloß
ohne Werbung, in länger
publishen. Das ist dann so eine Art Netflix
organisiert von bestimmten YouTubern.
Was Deutsch ist, was Englisch ist?
Englisch.
Ich habe nie gehört, Nebula, okay.
Vielleicht muss ich es mal abonnieren und dann kann ich da mal eine Rezession
so abgeben. Also zum Beispiel, ich gucke
gerne so Adam Neely.
Das ist einfach
ein Musiker, der stundenlang über Musik rummördert,
über irgendeine bestimmte
Harmoniefolge oder was.
Okay. Hast du, glaube ich, auch schon mal erzählt.
Irgendwann die Richtung zumindest schon mal angesprochen.
So viel zum Thema Corona-Hobbys.
Hast YouTube
durchgeschaut. Fürchterlich.
Was gibt es denn sonst noch bei dir Neues?
Einen Moment
der Stille.
Ich habe tatsächlich jetzt die
letzte Woche meinen Job gekündigt.
Oh nein. Das war mal
ein Erlebnis habe ich bisher nie gemacht.
Sitzt du jetzt auf der Straße?
Ich sitze jetzt auf der Straße.
Nee, ich habe ein cooles neues Angebot bekommen.
Ein Angebot, über das ich lange nachgedacht habe
und wir evaluiert haben zusammen.
Also der Angebotsstellende und ich.
Und letztendlich bin ich zu dem Interesse gekommen,
das muss ich annehmen.
Denn es geht darum,
einen Matrix-Client mitzuschreiben.
Machst du das nicht schon?
Ja, es war auch ursprünglich die Idee,
ob man da vielleicht irgendwie Nio mit übernehmen könnte,
forken könnte, was auch immer.
Da hat sich ein bisschen verlaufen gehabt,
in ein paar Details, die
nicht zuletzt haben wir
clevererweise mit Lio eine Lizenz
genommen gehabt, die sowas verbietet. Nicht, dass man da auch
Möglichkeiten finden würde, aber...
Hast du dir selber an den Fuß geschossen?
Ich sehe Nio auch nicht als möglicherweise
die beste Wahl an der Stelle, vor allem, wenn man
in Nio schon noch einiges in Arbeit reinstecken
müsste. Es ist
auch nicht die schönste Coldplay, es ist
jemals wirklich schön, aber
in Nio muss man beträchtlich mehr Arbeit reinstecken,
als wenn man jetzt Element iOS forken würde.
Und genau das ist dann der eigentliche Plan.
Einfach weil Neo noch so
jung und unumfangreich ist.
Genau, da gibt es ein paar größere offene Baustellen,
nicht zuletzt die Attack-Equipition.
Hast du nicht Neo erst angefangen,
extra weil du noch einen rein Swift-Plient
bauen wolltest? Neo war von Anfang an
mit einem Swift-UI-Playground, also um
dieses UI-Framework-App mitzunutzen.
Das hat natürlich viele
Stöcke in die Speichen gesteckt,
aber
im Großen und Ganzen funktioniert das auch ganz gut.
Neo kann man nutzen aktuell,
keine Notifications, es hat noch keine Verschlüsselung,
aber abgesehen davon kann man es tatsächlich
sogar nutzen.
Das funktioniert, aber ist natürlich, wie gesagt,
noch endlich in den Baustellen offen. Das ist ein bisschen einfacher,
wenn du dein Element, was schon fertig ist,
was heißt fertig, aber wo halt
quasi alles schon drin ist, was man aktuell braucht.
Das ist quasi die Referenzimplementierung.
Es ist die Referenzimplementierung.
Und zwar ist das ein Startup, wo ich da
jetzt demnächst angestellt bin,
wo heißt Beeper,
so wie ein Pager
auch genannt wird.
Und prinzipiell ist die Idee dahinter, wir bauen einen Matrix-Client,
beziehungsweise wir hosten einen Matrix-Server, Home-Server für Geld für Kunden,
die wollen, dass direkt die Bridges mit integriert sind.
Und da sind halt die ganzen Bridges für andere Dienste schon mit gehostet.
Und das ist eigentlich ganz witzig.
Ich habe es die letzten Wochen auch mit schon benutzt und habe es aktiv am Laufen.
Funktioniert auch eigentlich ganz gut, weil es halt auch so witzige Features hat.
Es ist zum Beispiel eine iMessage-Bridge mit drin.
Und gerade iMessage ist halt dieses wundersame Ding,
was du halt nicht serverseitig anbridgen kannst,
weil es gibt keine Komponente, mit der du sprechen kannst.
iMessage ist komplett end-to-end encrypted
und so wie das System funktioniert, läuft das nur auf Apple-Geräten
und nur da kommst du an die Nachrichten ran.
Das heißt, die iMessage-Bridge, im Gegensatz zu den anderen Sachen,
läuft halt auf deinem Device und spricht halt direkt mit iMessage im Hintergrund
beziehungsweise spricht direkt mit der SQLiteDB,
beziehungsweise liest da die Daten raus,
beziehungsweise spricht über AppleScript mit dem iMessage-Client,
mit dem Messages-App, um da Daten reinzuschreiben,
was super witzig ist.
Die anderen Sachen laufen wie klassische Bündnis,
also Twitter, Instagram, Telegram, WhatsApp, Discord, Slack,
IRC, die laufen halt im Backend auf den Servern von Beeper,
netterweise auf europäischen Servern für europäische Kunden,
das finde ich ganz angenehm,
und laufen halt da deine Daten mit rein.
Signal Bridge gibt es auch sogar, das ist auch ganz cool.
Aber ich finde es ganz cool, weil es ein Matrix-Client ist.
es ist primär eine Matrix-Implementierung,
die wir da machen. Es ist ein Matrix-Server,
für den Leute bezahlen, aber weil halt die
Bötes mit dabei sind. Und das Coole ist,
dass man halt so Leute schon
früher auf die Plattform kriegen kann und
zu Matrix mitkriegen kann. Und auf lange Sicht
ist halt natürlich das Endziel, dass du die Bötes
logischerweise nicht mehr brauchst. Aber ob wir da jemals hinkommen,
ist halt die andere Frage. Aber so kannst du
schon einen guten Matrix-Client benutzen und da werde
ich die iOS-App mit
in Zukunft mit entwickeln. Cool. Und da
habe ich mega Bock drauf. Darfst du überhaupt drüber reden?
Ich habe kein NDA unterschrieben, fällt mir gerade auf.
Noch nicht.
Das ist ja witzig.
Doch, doch.
Ich kann drüber reden.
Ist ja auch nicht geheim.
Du hast mir jetzt nichts erzählt, was ja nicht auf dieser Website steht.
Eben, eben.
Ich gehe jetzt mal nicht in die Details rein, aber da ist eigentlich nichts Geheimes dabei an der Stelle.
Man kann sich aktuell schon anmelden, wie das Onboarding läuft.
Die Leute werden einzeln zugelassen, weil es aktuell noch viele raue Stellen gibt.
es funktioniert, man kann es mit Nutzen schon.
Es ist ein witziges Projekt
auf jeden Fall. Und was ich ganz cool finde, ist der
Gründer von dem Laden, der Eric,
ist, by the way, der Typ, der die Pebble damals
gestartet hat. Da wollte ich mir irgendwann mal
eine holen, die gab es dann plötzlich nicht mehr.
Ja, irgendwann ist die Firma halt zugrunde
gegangen, weil Apple die Apple Watch rausgebracht hat
und den Markt irgendwie so ein bisschen übernommen hat.
Pebble nicht gekauft worden von
Fitbit oder so? Ah, ich glaube auch, ja.
Die haben es dann, glaube ich, gekauft, um es einfach einzustellen.
Ja, Fitbit wollte ja eigentlich noch mit in den Markt
einsteigen. Kurz vorher hatten die noch so
krasses Teil herausgebracht. Die Geschichte
musst du mal erfragen, wenn du mit jemandem ein Bier trinkst.
Ist ja auch das andere dann.
Aber probiert trinken. Das ist halt alles komplett
remote. Wir sind halt verteilt
über, es sind nicht viele Leute, die aktuell dabei sind,
aber wir sind halt verteilt über die gesamte Welt.
Und das ist halt dann komplett
remote, remote. Also nicht nur
auch jenseits von Covid.
Aber remote. Ist schon ein bisschen spaßig.
Mal schauen, vielleicht nach Covid, vielleicht irgendwie mal so
ein Coworking-Space in Dresden mit anbieten, dass man
zumindest nicht nur zu Hause sitzt,
so wie aktuell.
Auf jeden Fall.
Wenn du irgendwann mal einen Job...
Ich hoffe nicht, dass es so weit kommt, aber ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass es so weit kommt, dass es heißt, ach, du bist
Softwareentwickler und du arbeitest natürlich von zu Hause aus.
Wir brauchen noch keine Büros.
Das ist hoffentlich nicht der Standard, aber Remote
als Option anbieten sollte Standard sein.
Das auf jeden Fall. Da sind wir ja auch, glaube ich,
mittlerweile an dem Punkt, wo die Firmen das eigentlich alle
eingesehen haben, dass es funktioniert. Auf jeden Fall.
Sicherlich wird es einige geben, die am Ende sagen,
hier, Covid ist vorbei, kommen bitte alle wieder mit ins Büro.
Aber
die große Mehrheit, glaube ich,
Gerade als Startup kannst du ja gar nicht anders,
als eigentlich zu sagen, hier, Büro, können wir das eigentlich nicht, oder?
Oder wahrscheinlich war es bei vielen häufig noch im Venture Capital mit eingepreist,
dass du sagst, natürlich brauchen wir Büro für wie viele Leute,
dann machen wir das jetzt halt irgendwo.
Also drei Leute mehr bezahlen.
Ja, stimmt eigentlich.
Und dann haben halt manche Startups irgendwie einen Container irgendwo am Rand der Stadt gehabt oder sowas
und dann musstest du dort sein, auch nicht geil.
Container am Rand der Stadt, witzig.
Warum nicht, kann man auch machen.
Ja? Nein, hätte ich keinen Bock drauf,
aber ist eine Option. Ja, krass,
cool. Aber ja, ich glaube
in Matrix habe ich richtig Lust.
Das wird cool. Das heißt,
du hast die rote Pille geschluckt? Ich habe die
rote Pille. Ich kann mir nicht merken, welche welche ist.
Aber ich glaube, es ist auch, also ich gehe
dir einfach jetzt nach, dass es die rote ist.
Das passt auch besser,
weil ich glaube, es gibt diese Red Pill Community,
diese komischen Weirdos da.
Die glauben, dass sie in der Matrix sind, oder was?
Nee, das hat irgendwie sowas mit,
Hat das nicht irgendwann mit Incels zu tun oder so?
What? Okay.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Egal, seid dahin gestellt. Ich glaube, die rote Pille war die,
um aufzuwachen.
Oh, dieses
wach endlich auf.
Ganz ehrlich, ich kann mir den Titel,
der Aufwachen-Podcast,
das ist ja dieser mit...
Keanu Reeves.
Nee, wo auch
Thilo Jung mitmacht.
Ach, okay.
Und ich kann sagen, dieser Aufwachen-Begriff,
der ist für mich verbrannt.
Wegen den Querdenkern?
Wegen den Querdenkern.
So wie der Begriff
Querlenker.
Wie der Begriff
Volk verbrannt ist irgendwie.
Oder
Atomkraftwerk.
Warum Atomkraftwerk verbrannt?
Das ist zumindest
Leute, die pro sind,
sagen Kernkraftwerk oder
Kernenergie und die Leute, die da gegen sind, sagen Atomkraftwerk.
Ich verstehe. In der Hinsicht verbrannt.
Ich kenne übrigens, der Kontext ist gerade nicht klar gewesen.
Ne,
was ist denn sonst noch so passiert?
Ich habe hier auf der Liste noch so ein Thema mit Basecamp
stehen, so hochaktuell.
Hast du da den Spaß mitbekommen?
Ich habe irgendwie den Begriff Basecamp gelesen und dann bist
du in dieser Situation, dass du
irgendwie auf Twitter bereits Kommentare liest,
wo du weißt, die Leute haben Kontext und das,
was sie schreiben, verstehst du nur, wer den Kontext ist.
Aber ich weiß immer noch nicht, worum es geht.
Ich hätte dann manchmal gerne bei Twitter so dieses
What's the context of this?
So eine AI in meinem
der Client, wo ich
sagen kann, wo kommt
eigentlich dieses Wissen her?
Und dann habe ich es irgendwie
in meine Pocket geschoben, aber bis jetzt noch nicht
gelesen. Was ist denn da passiert?
Generell zu dem Thema noch,
Out of the Loop zu sein. Ich schaue da meistens auf den Subreddit
Out of the Loop in der Hoffnung, dass da was steht.
Aber ich glaube, da stand noch gar nichts zu der
Basecamp-Sache. Das ist mehr so zwar allgemein im Internet,
aber
das ist immer sehr gut, vor allem wenn man nach New sortiert.
Da findet man schnell mal
einen Hinweis dazu.
What's everyone all about?
Sehr schön, das kommt in die Show Notes.
Nee, ansonsten hatte ich früher mal
einen Twitter-Client benutzt, der hatte
in der Liste der Trending-Hashtags
einen Button mit dran, wo
du eine Erklärung bekommen hast, warum das trendet,
was es damit auf sich hat und was das bedeutet.
Und wenn es halt keine Erklärung gab,
das war halt die Crowdsour, da konntest du noch eine submitten,
die wurden dann aber reviewed noch und dann
gab es halt eine. Twitter sollte
so ein Feature bitte mal einbauen in First Party.
Auf jeden Fall. Gerade so, wenn
diese Trending-Seite, warum trendet
da Dubai? Warum?
Ja, warum trendet
in Deutschland Hitler groß?
Ja, was war das denn bitte für ein paar Tagen?
Welches Jahr haben wir denn?
Why is this interesting? Es gab irgendwo einen Account,
der hieß, why is this
tweet funny?
Den könntest du tanken und
der hat dir dann den Witz erklärt.
Oh, das ist ja geil.
So, was ist denn jetzt bei Basecamp
passiert? Ich bin out of the loop, Kerl, Jan.
So wie ich das mitbekommen habe jetzt, da fehlt bestimmt mal ein bisschen was
in Informationen, aber das ist so meine Auffassung
aktuell, hat Basecamp
als Firma eine neue Policy
ins Spiel gebracht, dass sie gerne
auf Arbeit keine politischen Statements
mehr haben wollen, weil Politik ist
was, was man zu Hause bespricht und nicht
in dieser
freien Zone der Arbeitswelt,
wo man gefälligst mit seinen Kollegen
nur auf positiven Vibes unterwegs
sein sollte und nicht diese Themen mit anspricht, die ja
so böse sind. Warum machen wir das nachdem, Trump
abgewählt wurde.
Warum die das überhaupt machen,
ist generell eine Frage. Das ist so ein Ding,
was irgendwie für mich typisch amerikanisch
ist, ehrlich gesagt, dass man über Religion und Politik
nicht redet, weil die Fronten da so
verhärtet sind, dass man sich eh nur noch streitet.
Das Problem ist halt generell, du kannst
dich halt nicht verabschieden davon.
Alles, was wir machen als Menschen,
vor allem auch mit in der Tech-Welt, aber
letztendlich alles, was wir als Menschen machen, ist
irgendwo mit da verankert und du kannst
dich nicht einfach davon verabschieden. Du kannst dich die Augen
zumachen und so tun, als ob es keine
sozialen Probleme mehr gibt, die wir jetzt besprechen können.
Nee, Pech, die sind halt da.
Und das war Kritikpunkt Nummer eins.
Dann ist rausgekommen, dass
bei Basecamp intern so eine Liste
über Jahre rumgeflogen ist,
wo sie sich über die in Anführungsstrichen
lustigsten Kundennamen
lustig gemacht haben. Die haben sie da
in einem Shared Document irgendwo reingeschrieben.
Also Namen
von Menschen, die sie lustig
fanden.
Und das ist auch echt
Ja, sollte man nicht machen.
Und vor allem, wie es dann später gezeigt hat,
vor allem auch in einem
eher rassistischen Kontext, also
Namen, die halt, ich habe keine Beispiele,
weil sie die natürlich nicht veröffentlicht haben,
besser so, aber
das war wohl auch sehr rassistisch angehaucht
und ich will nicht sagen motiviert, weil ich den Leuten das nicht
unterstellen möchte, aber zumindest, dass die
Witze, auf die sie da angesprungen sind,
eher in die Richtung ging, dass sie halt
really, das ist jetzt
der Grund, warum du das da drauf schreibst.
Peinlich.
Und jetzt, gerade heute aktuell,
hat wohl DHH,
unser allseits beliebter Rennfahrer
und Rails-Entwickler,
der Chef von Basecamp,
für die, die den Kontext da nicht haben,
noch einen längeren Post
rausgeschrieben,
Blogpost rausgeschrieben, wo er die ganze
Sache nochmal mit anspricht, sich darüber
beschwert, dass Leute sich darüber beschweren
und das alles mit verharmlost und
irgendwie so ein bisschen sehr komisch
argumentiert im Sinne von
wir meinten das doch aber gar nicht so und das war
doch aber auch alles witzig und weil das witzig war,
dann passt das doch. Natürlich hat er das nicht so direkt
geschrieben, aber
es ist alles irgendwie so eine komische Situation
und es hat alles so einen richtig ekelhaften
Beigeschmack gerade und gefühlt hat er
sich noch viel mehr in die Scheiße reingeritten und
also mich würde es echt nicht wundern, wenn
das jetzt richtig hier
Also Basecamp wird quasi gerade gecancelt
oder wie? Vor allem durch sich selber halt
also
sie ermöglichen anscheinend auch vielen Mitarbeitern
gerade sie zu kündigen mit großen Abfindungen.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute das in Anspruch nehmen,
aber ich könnte mir gut vorstellen,
dass das Basecamp, also ich kann mir nicht gut vorstellen,
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass Basecamp so oder so nicht gut aus der Sache rausgeht wird.
Das ist schon entschieden zu spät.
So wie sie sich aktuell positioniert haben,
gerade weil DHH halt auch jemand ist,
der nicht locker lässt bei sowas.
Der hält halt fest dagegen.
Und auch damals, als sie mit Hey.com
diesen riesen Tritt gegen Apple losgetreten haben,
wo sie dann Probleme hatten,
weil Apple den Sign-Up in der App nicht einsehen wollte.
Ach, die Geschichte, ja, stimmt. Das hatten wir auch.
Da haben sie halt auch, natürlich
nicht locker gelassen, aber so richtig, richtig
in die Medien reingesprungen.
Und das ist halt voll sein Ding halt, von DHH
persönlich, aber auch von
Basecamp an der Stelle. Die haben sich halt schon immer hingestellt,
als wir sind so die transparenteste Firma überhaupt.
Wir sind ein super Arbeitgeber,
wir sind ultra transparent, wir machen alles
öffentlich, bis auf die Dinge, die personenspezifisch
sind. Und das
beißt sie aber gerade wieder so ein bisschen richtig.
hart. Und es läuft
alles richtig eklig. Also ich habe, wie gesagt,
alle Details habe ich sowieso nicht dazu.
Aber was machst du denn, wenn du in einer Firma bist und dann
machen sich so Leute
einen Slack-Channel auf, wo sie untereinander Scheiße
schreiben? Dann stellst du dich
danach nicht als CEO hin und verteidigst das.
Okay, hast recht.
Aber ich meine, klar, kann passieren
und ist wahrscheinlich bei den meisten Firmen auch so, dass du immer
Leute dabei hast, die halt irgendwo einen privaten Kommunikations-Channel
aufmachen und lästern
oder Scheiße schreiben. Oder im
Worst Case bist du bei der Polizei und die haben halt einen Nazi-Chat
aufgemacht. Oder
sowas in die Richtung.
Auf jeden Fall.
Du musst irgendwie damit umgehen und
ich meine, im einfachsten Case
haust du die Leuten halt auf die Hände und sagst,
ey, das geht so nicht. Logisch.
Oder im Worst Case, wenn es
eh öffentlich ist oder wenn es was Schlimmes ist, wie
Nazi-Polizisten, dann tut mir leid, dann sind die Leute
halt nicht tragbar, dann muss das raus. Und dann musst
du halt auch, wenn es öffentlich ist, öffentlich
kommunizieren, warum das so ist, warum die Leute
weg müssen und nicht halt den Scheiß
letztendlich verteidigen und das war doch
Ich finde das krass, dass das immer wieder passiert, solche Geschichten. Ich habe neulich eine recht gute Doku über Cancel Culture gesehen. Ich will das jetzt nicht gleichstellen, aber dass das irgendwie so ein Ding ist, dass manchmal was über dich rauskommt oder über Leute rauskommt, was irgendwie hornalt ist oder sowas und dann hast du irgendwie verkackt und dann wirst du einmal so durchs Internet getrieben, so als Coup durchs Dorf und dann finden dich alle scheiße und irgendwie ist es ziemlich schade.
schwierig, also häufig
ist es berechtigt.
Es ist halt das Schwierige, weil es sich halt berechtigt
anfühlt. Aber es hat natürlich
es macht halt super, es ist halt
super einfach, einfach auf diesen Zug mit aufzuspringen
und mitzumachen und zu sagen,
was haben die gemacht? Ja, die sind ja voll kacke.
Ich glaube, wir müssen kollektiv als Mensch halt
irgendwie noch ein bisschen lernen, mit sowas umzugehen.
Das ist so, ich glaube, das ist das, was halt so,
auch so ein Effekt des Internets ist. Auf jeden Fall.
Dass du merkst, ah,
guck mal, da ist irgendwie was Schlimmes passiert,
da müssen wir jetzt dagegen sein.
oder sowas, obwohl in Kontext gar nicht, also
häufig kriege ich solche Sachen
out of the loop, kriege ich jetzt solche Sachen erst später mit
und dann denke ich mir, was ist da jetzt überhaupt
passiert, dann sind natürlich alle schon wesentlich weiter
informiert als ich und dann
denke ich mir manchmal, okay, das ist krass,
ich kann jetzt keine Beispiele aufzählen,
weil ich will auch nichts runterspielen, weil es häufig auch
die Leute schlimme Sachen machen,
aber irgendwie finde ich es krass, dass es manchmal
jemanden trifft, wo du denkst,
was der, achso, der hat vor 10 Jahren
mal einen rassistischen Tweet gemacht
und danach nie wieder oder sowas
Wo man sich denkt, naja gut, okay, wir haben uns auf dem Schulhof auch rassistische Witze erzählt, weil wir es irgendwie als Kinder in Ostend schon nicht anders wussten oder sowas. Und dann heute denke ich mir, what the fuck, sowas würde ich eigentlich nie arbeiten.
Ja klar. Das ist echt schwierig. Ich habe auch letztens eine interessante Unterhaltung darüber gehabt, dass du ja als Politiker eigentlich…
Das habe ich gesagt, dass ich früher mal ein Rassist.
Ich habe letztens eine interessante Unterhaltung dazu gehabt, dass Politiker ja die Immunität, also die rechtliche Immunität vor allem auch deswegen mithaben, dass du halt nicht als Politiker dich hinstellst und dir letztendlich gar nichts traust, aus Angst vor rechtlichen Konsequenzen.
Also wenn jetzt unser allseits beliebter Scheuer-Andy persönlich für die Maut-Scheiße mit aufkommen müsste, dann hätte er natürlich niemals, ich will nicht sagen, es wäre besser, wenn er es nicht gemacht hätte, also es wäre besser, wenn er das Maut-Debakel nicht gemacht hätte, aber wenn er persönlich dafür haften würde, dann würde er natürlich nie sich wagen, irgendwas zu machen.
Und natürlich sollen Politiker auch sich trauen können, Dinge zu tun, die halt potenziell ein Griff in die Scheiße sind, weil du es halt vorher nicht wissen kannst. Und deswegen, unter anderem, deswegen ist so ein Immunitätskonzept sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Wenn wir jetzt dieses Ding haben, dass wir aufgrund von der Cancel Culture immer, dass du befürchten musst, dass du durch einen Griff ins Klo halt weg vom Fenster bist. Ich meine, gut, das ist ein anderer Griff ins Klo, ein viel schlimmerer Griff ins Klo, wenn du, keine Ahnung, jetzt dich hinstellst und rassistische Mails verschickst, die dann wieder öffentlich werden, als wenn du hier in deinem Amt als Politiker was verkackst, aber jetzt mal auf die Corona-Situation bezogen.
Du bist jetzt Jens Spahn und du machst eine dumme Entscheidung, weil, oder du sagst öffentlich was Dummes oder auch noch was leicht Beklopptes, wie das er gestern oder heute, wann das war, rausgehauen hat, von wegen aktuell ist jeder Vierte im Deutschen geimpft, morgen wird es jeder Fünfte sein, was natürlich ein bisschen blödsinnig ist, weil er studierte Bankkauf, eigentlich studierte, weil er Bankkaufmann gelernter ist, ist ein bisschen bitter, aber ich meine, sowas mal dahingestellt, aber sowas in der Richtung, sag mal, der sagt aus, was richtig Bekloppt ist, was Richtung Corona-Politik, was ja eigentlich sein Job aktuell auch ist,
Was? Und dann kommt halt das Internet und verteufelt ihn deswegen. Da gibt es halt, also er hätte halt dann die Konsequenzen der Cancel Culture zu fürchten, die ihm halt, wo ihm seine Immunität nichts bringt. Und potenziell traut er sich halt in seiner Rolle als Gesundheitsminister dann auch bestimmte Dinge nicht. Genau deswegen, weil halt diese Immunität dann nicht mehr greift. Das fand ich einen interessanten Punkt. Das ist ja auch, dass du die Konsequenzen davon mit befürchten müsstest. Ich meine, gut, wie gesagt, das ist alles nicht das Gleiche.
Es gibt immer mal Geschichten, dass jetzt irgendwie
dann beschlossen wird, dass die Immunität eines
Politikers aufgehoben wird. Zumindest in
gewisser Weise, ja. Aber stell dir vor,
du bist Jan-Josef Liefers und du machst so
ein Video, was
super geschmacklos ist.
Und hinterher denkst du dir so,
ja, eigentlich habt ihr recht, es war total geschmacklos.
Ja, ich
habe ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz so alles mitbekommen
von diesem Alles-Dicht-Machen.
Ich habe mir auch bloß dieses eine Video
angeguckt, ehrlich gesagt. Aber es war schon
ganz schön tone-deaf.
Es war ein bisschen Tone-Def von dem, was ich mitbekommen habe, ja. Auf der anderen Seite, nur weil ich es nicht verstanden habe, so komplett dahinter, waren das Leute, die Corona, also nicht geleugnet haben, aber waren das Leute, die wollten, dass jetzt alles dicht gemacht wird oder waren das Leute, die sich über die Politik lustig gemacht haben, die dicht machen wollen?
Die Aussage war so, ja, und damit wir, damit es richtig schlimm, weil, weil das hat irgendwie, ich krieg's nicht, ich krieg's auch nicht wiedergegeben.
Es kam halt völlig falsch rüber.
Da waren auch so Witze über nicht atmen können oder sowas.
Aber sie haben doch, okay, aber das habe ich schon richtig verstanden in die Richtung, dass die halt völlig überspitzt die aktuelle Situation wiedergegeben haben, wie es halt ist.
dass man noch richtig dumm daherkommt
und die aktuelle Situation einfach mal so richtig kaputt machen,
im Sinne von, wir dürfen jetzt gar nicht mehr und so müsste es sein.
Und das einfach letztendlich als Anspielung darauf.
So könnte man die Politik noch richtig bekloppt machen.
Aber eigentlich wollen wir ja, dass alles nicht gemacht wird,
damit wir das sinnvoll damit umgehen.
Wenn man in der Interpretation den Leuten ein bisschen entgegenkommt,
dann kann man sich sagen,
ich kann mir vorstellen, was ihr damit ausdrücken wolltet,
aber es kommt halt leider überhaupt nicht rüber.
Okay.
Aber wenn man es halt falsch auslegen
wollte, dann könnte man auch sagen,
das klingt ganz schön nach AfD,
was ihr hier gerade sagt.
Weil es halt nicht, das war halt
zynisch und nicht sarkastisch.
Also die Absicht dahinter war
eher in Anführungsstrichen nobel, aber sie haben es halt
richtig dumm rübergebracht. Sie haben es einfach schlecht gemacht.
Okay, jetzt habe ich es verstanden.
Sie haben es einfach wirklich schlecht gemacht.
Übrigens, heute ist jeder Vierte und morgen
jeder Fünfte geimpft.
mein Pick
dieses Mal ist
der Twitter-Bot
Impf-Progress.
Impf-Progress, okay.
Das ist sowas wie Year-Progress?
Kennst du diesen Jahres-Counter?
Den habe ich, den kenne ich.
Es gibt hier einen, der twittert
alle N Stunden
und es sind momentan, laut diesem
Twitter-Bot, dem ich natürlich sehr vertraue,
sind momentan 25,9% der Leute
erst geimpft. In Deutschland.
In Deutschland.
äh, das ist hier
äh, dieser Bot
tweetet den aktuellen Impffortschritt
für Deutschland, Quelle ist
impfdashboard.de
kein offizieller Account des BMG oder
RKI, so
äh, finde ich aber sehr lustig, da hast du einfach diese zwei
diese zwei Statusbiken, die getwittert werden
ich mag hier sowas, da hast du dann ab und zu immer dabei
das ist sowas, was du nicht ständig nachgucken willst, was du aber auch
nicht ständig in euren Nachrichten unbedingt haben
möchtest
ja, ja, ja, fließt die dann mal ganz kurz
aber finde ich witzig, ich mag solche
Aber jeder Vierte ist halt
erst geimpft.
Ja, und sieben Prozent
sind vollständig geimpft.
Wir kommen gut voran hier.
Läuft bei uns.
Ich stehe bei seinem Hautsatz auf der Warteliste
aktuell und ich hoffe, dass sie mich demnächst
anruft, dass ich mal
Dass du hier Astra-Urtyp geimpft kriegst.
Ich hätte
echt gar nicht diese Scheiß-Impfung.
Gib mir Astra.
Ich will es haben.
Ich habe gestern zum ersten Mal wieder Astra geholt.
Das habe ich dann an der Elbe getrunken.
Hat sich das gerade bewegt?
Nee, das wird doch nicht aktualisiert.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Achso, da gab es ja diesen Arzt, der irgendwie rumgeschrieben hat,
hier, ich sitze noch auf Dosen fest.
Ja, der war ja in der 6. Zeitung, der in,
na, hinten raus, Kesselsdorf.
Aber das wird doch nicht, warum denn dieser eine Arzt?
Der eine Arzt hat so viele Dosen,
der hat Dosen bekommen, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr als andere Ärzte,
aber der hat vor allem sehr viele Patienten gehabt,
die es nicht haben wollten.
Ich kann mir doch vorstellen, dass sich das so rausmittelte,
dass es bei fast allen Ärzten so sein wird.
Kann sein, hängt sicherlich davon ab.
Aber auf jeden Fall war dieser eine Arzt in der Sächsischen Zeitung
und der hat halt sehr viele Anfragen dann bekommen gehabt.
Von den Interessenten.
Der ist hier bestimmt noch losgeworden, oder?
Ja, das war zwei Tage später in der Sächsischen Zeitung der Artikel,
dass ja den Typen lächeln und nicht mehr so,
wie sie behältig gucken, wie vorher so dingen, alle Dosen weg.
Fand ich witzig.
Und bei meiner Hausärztin stehe ich auch mit auf dem...
Verimpf mal 400 Dosen an einem Tag.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das nach einem Tag rausging, aber...
Oh Mann.
Du hast mal bei deiner
Herrsärztin angefragt? Genau, und da stehe ich auf der
Alter, Kilian, wir werden alt, wir reden über
unsere Hausärzte. Ja, aber ich rede doch nicht
über meine Leiden, dass mein Knie wird in der
Knie, tut nicht weh. Wenn wir uns übrigens hinsetzen, wir machen
diese Folge schon seit einer dreiviertel Stunde im Stehen.
Ja, es ist die erste Folge, die wir komplett im Stehen aufnehmen.
Wir haben schon mal eine Folge ohne Hosen
gehabt und jetzt ist eine Folge, wo wir
im Aski saßen, wo es so geregnet hat.
Mit Jupp? Ja, genau. Mit Jupp saßen wir da.
Alter, hat das geschüttet.
Oder hat nur Juk keine Hose angehabt?
Das weiß ich gerade gar nicht mehr.
War zumindest alles anders.
Aber ja, wir hatten mal eine Folge ohne Hosen.
Das ist jetzt einfach mein Headcanon,
dass wir alle ohne Hosen da saßen.
Und heute ist eine Folge nur umstehen.
Und schauen wir mal, was das in Zukunft ist.
Ich habe einfach mir mit diesem wunderschönen,
höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch von einem halben Jahr geholt.
Das ist echt was wert.
Das ist ein Feature.
Den Unterbau habe ich erst letzte Woche verschenkt.
Aber der ist doch hier.
Den von dem alten.
Den Vierbeiner, meinen treuen Vierbeiner.
Ich bin ja gleich dazu reingestellt.
Als treuen Vierbeiner auch?
Ja.
Sehr schön.
Ähm...
Ja.
Du warst gerade bei deiner Hausärztin?
Äh, nee.
Achso, ja, thematisch.
Ich stehe auf der Warteliste in der Hoffnung,
da jetzt demnächst einen Anruf zu bekommen.
Sie haben mich auch sehr gerne auf die Warteliste genommen.
Sie haben sich darüber gefreut. Das fand ich auch ganz nett,
dass die Leute Interesse haben.
Und ich hoffe, dass das bedeutet,
dass noch nicht viele Leute vorher angerufen haben.
Und ich kann innerhalb von drei Minuten jederzeit da sein,
habe ich ihr gesagt.
Sehr gut.
I'm ready, my body is ready.
Snape-Gifter.
Ich kriege nach Schnitzschau,
als so eine Gummihäle,
den Arm ab und rennst hin.
Hier, bitte ansetzen.
Gib's mir.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe E-Mails bekommen in den letzten Wochen,
dass Konzerte, für die ich seit über einem Jahr Karten habe,
die erst von 20 auf 21
jetzt auf 22 verschoben werden.
Das ist auch geil.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich in zwei Jahren
die Karte noch habe.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Tinte auf dem
Papier so lange hält. Manchmal
kriegst du so einen Kassenzettel
bei einem Gerät, was irgendwie drei Jahre, fünf Jahre
garantiert, da sagen sie dir, bitte
mach da eine Fotokopie von, weil die Farbe sich
wahrscheinlich auflöst.
Ich hatte auch
für Ende 2020 ein Konzert,
habe ich noch Karten. Da kriege ich jetzt aktuell
wöchentlich eine E-Mail, wie es verschoben wird.
Wöchentlich? Ja, aber irgendwie ist glaube ich der
System kaputt, weil das wird jetzt seit drei Monaten
wird es immer wieder auf den, also die
Update-Mail ist immer dasselbe Datum
und derselbe Ort wie vorher.
Aber so habe ich zumindest immer oben in meinem
Posteingang die Erinnerung, das existiert
noch.
Dann archiviere ich immer die letzte
Mail davon und behalte immer nur die aktuelle.
Und ich habe immer im Downloads-Ordner jetzt seit über einem Jahr
diese Tickets liegen.
Ich finde ja, es sollten mehr Services
einfach einen Customized Kalender
anbieten. Wenn ich irgendwo,
das ist nicht Eventim, bei Eventim habe ich
fünf Tickets gekauft und gut, okay,
der Service ist nur, dass ich wissen muss,
dass die sich verschieben, weil
es sich tatsächlich verändert, aber man könnte
doch zum Beispiel sagen, hier unter
Slash so und so kriegst du einen Kalender, wo
nur deine Events drinstehen oder sowas.
Ja, das ist eigentlich komisch, dass die das noch nicht machen.
Also viele andere Sachen machen das. Meetup zum Beispiel
macht genau das. Stimmt.
Aber Eventim ist ja so eine Kackfirma,
wahrscheinlich kommen die da einfach nicht drauf, weil die so viel
Scheiße machen.
Du weißt schon wieder Sachen, die ich nicht weiß.
Die sind irgendwie so eine richtig ekelhafte Firma, die
andere Läden rauspressen aus dem
Geschäft. Ja, eben, und wollen das
natürlich auch bleiben. Die sind
komisch, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Aber da kann ich nicht so teilgehen, weil ich es nicht
weiß. Out of the Loop,
Eventim. Ich glaube, ich frage auf
Out of the Loop mal wegen der Basecamp-Sache. Ich hätte
mal eine genaue Erklärung. Das war echt ein
sehr angenehmer Sample, weil die ja wirklich erklären,
was anscheinend
ist hier
noch unanswered vor sieben Stunden.
What's the deal with
iOS 14.5's Tracking Feature?
Apropos iOS 14.5, du hast mir wohl
neue Emojis geschickt.
Ja.
Ich gucke immer
Late Show mit Stephen Colbert und da
gab es unter MeWire übrigens, es gibt jetzt
neue iOS. Es kommt dort. Und was ist
da jetzt das Coole?
Was hatte ich dir geschickt?
Das ist,
finde ich das noch?
Da war der Gag quasi.
Und jetzt gebe ich den 1 zu 1 wieder.
Oh, hier wird es noch nicht unterstützt.
Emoji One kann es noch nicht in Element.
Tragisch. Auf iOS habe ich es gesehen.
Der Face im Fog, der Face
mit dem Stern,
das brennende Herz, das zusammengepatchte Herz.
Ich glaube, der Joke ist,
Oh, there is weed at this party.
Ach so.
Oh, I partook in the weed in this party.
So drei Stunden später.
Irgendwas krasses, was man nur sagt,
super high ist irgendwie.
Es ist irgendwie Gesicht in Rauch,
Gesicht, ausatmendes
Gesicht und Gesicht mit
kringeligen Augen.
Das kriegst du nicht mehr zusammen.
Viel cooleres Feature.
Das ist schon wieder was, was überhaupt nicht hörbar ist.
Wir können ja nicht das Folgentitel packen, die Emojis,
das haben wir schon mal probiert.
Apple Podcast
ist daran gestorben,
den Feed zu publishen, als sie das Emoji
im Folgentitel.
Das müssen sie können.
Das heißt irgendwie auf Apple Podcasts,
das Backend muss mindestens auf iOS
14.5 laufen.
Ja, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass es Unicode kann.
Vor allem nicht im Folgentitel.
Ich glaube, wir machen einfach ein Disclaimer an diese Folge,
dass es ein bisschen eine sehr labrige Folge ist.
Das nächste Mal haben wir aber wahrscheinlich wieder einen Gast.
Was ich gerade sagen wollte,
also abgesehen davon, dass ich mich auch sehr
freue auf die nächste Gastfolge.
Das ist sehr cool.
Da wird er hoffentlich auch nicht allzu lang auf sich warten lassen.
Verspreche ich jetzt, es kommt im Oktober.
Nee, wir halten den Gast ja schon seit ein paar Wochen hin,
ehrlich gesagt sogar.
Stimmt.
iOS 14.5 hat ein sehr cooles Feature bekommen,
auf was ich mit den Betas sehr lange gewartet habe,
weil ich die Beta nicht installieren wollte.
Deswegen, für die aktuelle Situation,
wenn du draußen bist mit deinem Handy in der Hand
und du willst Face-ID nutzen,
trägst du aber eine Maske,
dann kannst du dein Handy nicht entsperren,
weil dein Face-ID dich nicht erkennt.
Und wenn du aber eine Apple Watch am Arm hast,
dann entsperrt sich dein Handy plötzlich.
Was sehr cool ist.
Was eigentlich, weißt du, was richtig geil wäre
an so einem iPhone?
Fingerabdrucksensor.
Das wäre super praktisch.
Also ich finde Face ID sehr viel angenehmer als Touch ID,
aber beides wäre echt nice to have.
Vielleicht kommt es ja im nächsten iPhone.
Das ist lange gerumored.
Ich muss sagen, also ich rante sehr gerne
über iOS.
Ich habe aus irgendeinem Grund,
ich besitze keinen Fernseher,
deswegen habe ich mir ein iPad geholt,
um in der Küche irgendwie beim Kochen
was gucken zu können.
Und ich dachte mir, ich packe es aus und denke mir, ich habe das allerbilligste iPad Air geholt, was es gibt. Ich packe es aus und denke mir, yes, es ist ein Charger dabei. So ein Charger, weil sie ja jetzt irgendwie auf Charger umsteigen, wo nicht ein normales USB drin ist, sondern USB-C. Da kann ich dieses eine Kabel, was ich beim Telefon dazu bekommen habe, reinstecken, wo es ja keinen Charger gab, obwohl es doberweise leider mein allererstes iPhone ist.
iPad-Netzteil gibt ja auch sehr viele angenehme
Filmschulen. So, und dann denke ich mir, geil, dann nehme ich
dieses Kabel und lege das irgendwo hin und dann kann ich
damit abwechselnd mein iPad
oder mein Telefon laden.
Nee, weil das iPad, genauso wie
der Laptop, lädt sich über USB-C
und das Telefon haben sie immer noch auf diesem scheiß
Lightning-Kabel.
Achso, du meinst die Seite
vom Kabel. Ich habe
noch nie so viele unterschiedliche
Kabel von nennen müssen, wie seitdem
ich auf iOS umgestiegen bin.
Ja, das mit Lightning und USB-C ist echt
nervig. Ich höre auch zwei Kabel
am Nachtisch extra. Mein altes Android
kann ich schon seit
fünf Jahren mit USB-C laden und
das Telefon von
Apple, die gleiche Firma,
die einen Laptop herstellt,
der nichts anderes mehr als
einen USB-C-Anschluss hat und
dessen Tablet sich mit USB-C laden,
lädt das Telefon aus
irgendeinem unauffälligen Grund immer noch mit
Lightning. Ja, ich meine, an sich ist
Lightning der bessere Anschluss,
weil er halt die
bei USB-C hast du...
Er ist schön schmal, das gibt es.
Genau, er ist schmaler, aber auf der anderen Seite steckst du halt das Stück
Metall, was raussteckt, in den Anschluss rein
und hast nicht bei USB-C eine Hülle,
also quasi
ein Metallelement mit einem Loch drin,
was du den Anschluss steckst, wo in der Mitte von dem
Anschluss noch ein Element steckt, was...
Theoretisch kannst du da was kaputt machen.
Du kannst es einfacher kaputt machen, das stimmt.
Auf der anderen Seite geht wohl bei USB-C,
wenn was kaputt geht,
eher lässt der Anschluss nach
und das Kabel hält nicht mehr ordentlich drin
und den Anschluss kannst du halt nicht so einfach tauschen,
wie ein Kabel.
Aber auf der anderen
Seite ist USB-C
halt einfach der Default geworden mittlerweile.
Also, ja,
das wäre ich mal an der Zeit.
Aber es hängt ja nicht nur noch am iPhone.
Alle anderen Peripheriegeräte,
ich sehe hier auf deinem Schreibtisch das Magic Keyboard, das Magic Trackpad,
die Magic Mouse.
Alle diese drei Geräte
haben Lightning Ports.
Ja, vor allem an einer sehr praktischen
Stelle für die Maus, ich weiß.
Das ist clever.
Ich glaube, immer noch der Grund dafür, dass du die Maus von unten lädst,
ist, dass Johnny Ive einfach
nicht wollte. Also die hätten es natürlich die ganze Zeit
das Kabel dran. Ja, weil es dann Leute
gäbe, die das Kabel dran hätten und das wollte er
nicht, dass das optisch so ein Ding ist.
Und das finde ich, ist natürlich maximal lächerlich.
Was natürlich Leute bei der Tastatur allerdings
machen, ne? Ja.
Absolut. Obwohl die Tastatur auch jahrelang hält.
Vor allem das Schöne auch an der Maus ist,
du kannst ja nicht mal... Wusstest du, dass die Räder
für den
Mac, für den, wie heißt der,
der Standrechner? Black Pro ist gleich teuer.
Dass die 700 Euro kosten?
Die scheiß Rollen?
Ja, du kriegst ein Fahrrad für wenige.
Du kriegst
einen ganzen Satz Winterreifen für dein Auto
für eine Rolle von dir.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Das Schöne an der Magic Maus zusätzlich ist noch,
du kannst nicht mal als Zubehörhersteller
daherkommen und einen ultraflachen Stecker
machen, der vielleicht unten dran
sehr angenehm glatt ist, dass du halt
reinstecken kannst, geht rechtwinklig raus
oder so und die ganze Maus bleibt dann noch über den Tisch.
Weil sobald diese Maus im Strom hängt,
disabelt sich die Touch-Oberfläche.
Die ganze Maus funktioniert nicht mehr, sobald die
im Strom ist. Also selbst das
haben sie irgendwie unterbunden damit.
So ein bisschen lächerlich.
Achso.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin mit dieser Tastatur sehr happy.
Ich finde die Magic Keyboard eine der besten Tastaturen überhaupt.
Wenn ich sehe, wie Leute auf diesen
riesenhohen mechanischen Tastaturen hacken,
dann kriege ich schon
vorhin zugucken sehen scheinende Entzündungen, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
die schwarze
Gibt's nur in Breit.
Achso, du hast gerne eine schwarze, schmale.
Ich hätte gerne eine schwarze, schmale.
Ich find die Breite besser.
Und wenn du dir die schmale holst, dann sind,
ich hab das zumindest gesehen bei den Tastaturen,
die sie jetzt vorgestellt haben für diesen neuen...
Die Metatardie, diese neuen.
Ja, genau. Bei denen ist
Option und der Fn-Key falsch rum.
Was? Die sind nicht konsistent, die Tastaturen.
Oh nein. Also diese Tastatur
mag ich, weil die eine normale Control ganz
außen links hat im Vergleich zu dem Laptop.
Und von dem neuen iMac die Tastatur,
Die hat einfach mal die Taste falsch.
Wir sind ja übelste Fanboy-Podcast geworden, weißt du das?
Die haben eine FN-Taste unten, dann Control, Option, Command.
Stimmt doch, Control, Option, Command.
Genauso wie beim MacBook.
Ja, aber FN gehört nicht nach ganz außen links.
Nee, da stimme ich dir zu.
Aber das ist bei den kleinen Tasters, bei den kleinen Magic Keyboards eh schon der Fall gewesen.
Eben.
Ja, nee, das stimmt absolut.
Die FN-Taste hat nichts da unten verloren.
Das nervt mich am MacBook schon.
Da bricht man sich doch den Finger.
Na gut, wie oft braucht man FN?
Nein, du brauchst FN nicht, aber wenn ich Steuerung drücke,
dann kann ich, dann, wenn ich,
drück mal Steuerung, Shift und mach eine Tassenkombination
damit. Ja, eben. Ja, das geht, aber
Steuerung, Control brauchst du halt auf dem Mac
nicht. Ich weiß.
Was übrigens das einzig
Sinnvolle ist, weil du so halt im fucking Terminal
auch kopieren und pasten kannst, weil
Control C nicht überbelegt ist. Das stimmt
allerdings. Ja, ich bin jetzt
erstens wieder viel auf Windows unterwegs und da renne
ich in Probleme, dass ich plötzlich meine
Tastaturkürzle alle verkacke und dann
versuche Fenster auf der falschen Seite zu schließen, dieses
Ich muss mich immer fünf Sekunden umgewöhnen,
wenn ich dann in meiner Freizeit wieder meinen
schönen Arch Linux Rechner nehme,
auf dem ich
jetzt endlich mal Steam installiert
habe. Ich habe ein Corona-Hobby.
Ich spiele jetzt zur Zeit Portal wieder.
Und ich denke mir jedes Mal,
ich bin gerade auf meinem Arch Linux
Rechner und ich spiele ein
Spiel.
Das geht nicht.
Ich habe zehn Jahre keine Spiele gespielt, seitdem ich
auf Linux umgestiegen bin.
Nämlich gerade an diesen
Da gab es aber so ein XKCD von wegen, ich spiele Spiele generell zehn Jahre später,
weil es auf meiner Hardwareprobleme laufen muss.
Und dann kommt irgendwie so der Dude reingerannt.
Guys, guys, the cake is a lie.
Und alle anderen sitzen da so.
Ja, naja, klar, auf jeden Fall.
Hendrik spielt jetzt Portal.
Ich spiele jetzt Portal.
Vorher habe ich Minecraft gespielt und davor habe ich StarCraft gespielt.
Letztes Jahr noch.
Und morgen Abend bin ich zu einer StarCraft-Runde wieder mit Kollegen verabredet.
Oha.
Ja.
Ich hätte mal wieder Bock auf eine LAN-Party.
Im ASCII, das war immer so cool.
Eine richtige LAN-Party?
Mit LAN?
Ja, im ASCII haben wir dann halt den Switch reingelegt.
Jeder hat ein Kabel gezogen.
Und dann haben wir StarCraft und
UT4,
also Unreal Tournament 2004
und irgendein COD.
Nee, nicht COD.
Command & Conquer. C und C.
Und irgendwelche anderen Sachen gespielt.
Aber UT4 hat mir am meisten Spaß gemacht.
Vor allem auf dieser einen Map mit den zwei großen Türmen.
Ich glaube, Face oder wie die hieß.
Das war einfach so viel Spaß gemacht.
Ich will Unreal Tournament spielen.
Meme Throwback.
Was haben wir sonst noch so in unserem Pad?
Ich meine, bis hier hört wahrscheinlich jetzt eh niemand mehr.
Nee, nee.
Da ist irgendein random YouTube-Account verlinkt.
Was ist das?
Ach so, noch so ein Corona-Hobby.
Ich habe diesen YouTube-Channel von...
In dem Link erkennt man es nicht mehr.
Wie heißt der Mensch?
Da kann ich nicht hinklicken.
Das muss ich jetzt wieder hierher kopieren
und dann muss ich das Markdown wegpasten.
Ich habe diesen YouTube-Channel von James Hoffman gefunden.
Der hat eigentlich bloß...
Ich hatte noch irgendwas Kaffeeartigem gesucht.
Und dann habe ich gesehen, der testet Kaffeemaschinen
und redet über, wie mache ich guten Espresso
und benutzt so Begriffe wie...
Das ist over-extracted oder under-extracted.
Ein Kaffeehipster.
Der ist ein Kaffeehipster, den musst du dir bloß angucken.
Da siehst du definitiv, dass der Mensch ein Kaffeehipster ist
und er spricht mit einem sehr geilen
englischen Akzent und er redet dann über
so abgefahrene Geräte wie
dieses
seltsame
Kaffeemaschine und zerlegt die.
Und ich muss sagen, es ist einfach unwahrscheinlich
entspannt, sich anzugucken, wie andere
Leute Kaffee kochen.
Und dann immer mal andere Kaffeemaschinen
ausprobieren.
Es gibt schon echt tolle YouTube-Accounts.
Ich habe jetzt noch den Lockpicking Royer
für mich entdeckt. Der hat immer so angenehm
kurze Videos. Die sind immer nur so eine Minute oder
zwei lang. Achso, was du hier gesehen hast, ist nicht Aldi,
sondern... Ach doch, da hat er eine
von Aldi gekauft. Die hat er komplett verrissen. Und sie
hat er sich alles von Ikea geholt und hat das
komplett gehasst.
Oh Mann.
Nämlich so ein bisschen
so ein Account, den ich schon seit Jahren
sehr gerne schaue. Der sagt aber
nichts. Der macht Messer.
Aus allem. Aus allem Möglichen.
Genau, aus Asche. So ein übelst scharfes Messer.
Aber davon habe ich mir fünf
angeguckt oder so und dann habe ich gesehen,
eigentlich macht er einfach bloß irgendwie eine harte Platte
und danach ist irgendwie aber
die restlichen 80% von Videos
sind immer bloß Video-Wärme beim Schleif.
Das waren die ersten Videos, wo es angefangen hat. Später werden die Videos
immer abstrusel. Also die aktuellen sind halt
irgendwie so, die halbe Zeit macht er halt irgendwie
ein Accessoire für seine Barbie
und dann macht er halt nebenbei
noch so ein Messer.
Der Typ ist schon sehr, sehr interessant.
Weiß auch nicht allzu viel
über alle Videos hinweg hat man so ein bisschen was rausbekommen.
Aber ich freue mich immer, wenn ein neues Video kommt.
Wie heißt denn diese Frau?
Wie ist die?
Laura.
Was ich auch neulich erst entdeckt habe,
ist eigentlich aus dieser Szene von Simone Järtsch,
so ein bisschen kommt, ist Laura Kampf.
Die ist aus Deutschland.
Ich kenne nur Simone Giertz.
Aber ja, die spricht natürlich ein bisschen Englisch aus.
Auf Schwedisch spricht sich das wohl Jetsch aus.
Zumindest,
ich gucke gerne auf Videos, wo Leute einfach auch was
bauen.
Und die säbelt vor allem sehr häufig
an Fahrrädern rum. Die hat zum Beispiel hier
einen Sackkarren und ein Fahrrad kombiniert.
Ein Fahrrad, was vorne ein Sackkarren
ist, was super praktisch ist. Wenn du zum Beispiel
dir nicht extra
ein Auto mieten möchtest, um dir einen Kasten
Kollematen zu holen.
Du wolltest...
Naja, okay.
Das war übrigens nicht nur ein Kassenkolle.
Ich habe die Schank auch gleich genutzt und ein bisschen mehr als das gekauft.
Das mache ich, wenn ich mal mit meinem Smart losfahre und tatsächlich,
ich gehe mal in den Getränkeladen.
Da gehe ich natürlich raus mit 200 Euro Getränken,
die dann irgendwie vier Monate halten oder sowas.
Weil ich habe ja schließlich Benzin dafür verbrannt.
Außerdem nutze ich Teilauto.
Das finde ich angenehm.
Da teile ich dann drei Euro für die halbe Stunde, die ich das brauche.
Ja, das ist ganz angenehm.
Gibt es die schon elektrisch?
Ja, leider nicht.
bei mir vor der Tür, aber sie haben elektrische.
In Dresden glaube ich so vier Stück.
Aber trotzdem, am Hauptbahnhof
steht ein, mit dem bin ich auch schon mal gefragt.
Der Golf fährt sich sehr angenehm.
Ich habe jetzt festgestellt, Elektroautofahrer sind irgendwie
sehr spät aktiv, nacht aktiv.
Weil ich sehe recht häufig, wenn ich so
21 Uhr,
was ja jetzt quasi schon ist,
wenn ich so 21 Uhr vor die Haustür gehe,
wenn ich 21 Uhr einkaufen gehe,
ich gehe mal relativ spät einkaufen, damit ich keinem begegne,
sehe ich an dieser Ladestation
immer diesen einen Tesla stehen und da sitzt immer der Fahrer
drin und guckt da bei YouTube-Videos.
Und dann sehe ich aber im
nächsten Moment noch zwei andere Teslas an mir
vorbeifahren. Ich denke mir so, sind die
irgendwie, treffen die sich hier zum
gemeinsamen Laden oder sowas?
Und dann könnte man sich richtig vorstellen,
dass es dann so Lade, hippe Lade
Gangs gibt, die
sich einmal die Woche zum Autoladen
fahrt und reden.
Das ist eine Ladenparty.
Eine Ladenparty.
Eine
Ladenparty?
Das ist ja witzig vor.
Ich habe letztens was Wissiges über Teslas erfahren.
Der Model 3.
Wenn der Strom ausfällt, kannst du die Türen von innen nicht mehr öffnen.
Und Strom kann zum Beispiel ausfallen,
wenn die Batterien plötzlich Feuer fangen.
Und dann ist es für ein Auto, was brennt,
wenn die Türen nicht aufgehen.
Oh, it's a death trap.
Was ist denn das für ein Construction Floor?
Das haben irgendwelche Whistleblower bei Tesla rausgehauen.
Von wegen, die, was war das?
Die Cooling Liquid.
Nee, war es die Cooling Liquid?
Kühlflüssigkeit?
Ja, passt aber gerade nicht. Ich meine vielleicht
irgendwas von den Batterien mit.
Ich meine, es war aber die Cooling Liquid.
Das ist Schmieröl, der Batterie.
Müssen wir nachschauen, was das genau war. Aber ich meine, es war die Cooling Liquid,
die ist natürlich nicht flammbar.
Es sei denn, sie ist trocken. Dann sehr.
Nicht?
Oh Gott.
What?
Okay.
Oh Mann.
Autos sind überhaupt nicht mein Thema, habe ich gesagt.
Nee, ich will auch kein Auto besitzen.
Ich bin sehr froh.
Ja.
Wollen wir die wirklich ausstrahlen, die Folge?
Das ist mir eine sehr
andere Folge geworden.
Naja, das ist einfach,
weil wir so
raus sind, so ein bisschen.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass wir aus dem Podcast raus sind,
aber wir haben jetzt immer diese Folgen,
die nach langen Pausen sind.
Es stimmt, wo man
theoretisch mehr Themen als sonst hat,
aber irgendwie genau das Gegenteil der Fall ist.
Und man hatte irgendwie
35 Themen sich zwischendurch mal gemerkt.
Die sind schon gar nicht mehr aktuell.
Und dann trifft man sich
so Hals über Kopf, wir müssen mal wieder eine Folge machen.
Und dann steht man fest, ich habe überhaupt gar nichts zu erzählen.
Wir haben ja auf Teufel komm raus
und die Stars zusammengekratzt hier vorhin.
Du hast den Impfprogress-Account und noch
ein anderes Projekt, was habe ich gefunden?
Ich habe ein cooles...
Föbot.
Genau, das klingt ein bisschen schwierig.
Der V-O-E-B-B.
Ich kann es ja nicht aussprechen.
Der VÖBB-Bot.
VÖBB-Bot.
Das ist eine Browser-Extension.
Die kannst du in deinem Browser installieren, wenn du einen Browser nutzt, der Extensions
kann.
Alle?
Es gibt keine Safari-Extension.
Es gibt eine Chrome-Extension.
Es gibt eine Firefox-Extension.
Und dann kannst du dich mit deinem VÖBB-Account anmelden.
Die VÖBB ist der Verein von...
Das hat überhaupt nichts mit öffentlichem Verkehr zu tun.
Das hat nichts mit öffentlichem Verkehr zu tun.
hat mit Artikeln im Internet zu tun.
Und der Verbund der öffentlichen
Bibliotheken Berlins, das ist der VÖBB,
da kannst du dich anmelden
für 10 Euro im Jahr, also
quasi für nichts, aktuell sogar kostenlos
für drei Monate dank Corona.
Und dann kriegst du theoretisch
über diesen Account Zugang
zu sehr vielen
Online-Medien
Paywall-Artikeln, ist so die Idee dahinter.
Da kannst du theoretisch
darüber dir die Print-Medien-Artikel
laden. Aber das ist natürlich sehr umständlich,
sich da in die passenden Portale anzumelden
und die Sachen rauszusuchen. Deswegen gibt es
diese Browser-Extension, da gehst du auf irgendeine
unterstützte Seite, du siehst ein Artikel
und dann siehst du unten die Paywall. Und bis du zur Paywall gescrollt hast,
hat dieses Add-on im Hintergrund schon den eigentlichen
Text geladen und substituiert
ihn dir einfach statt der Paywall in deine
Webseite live rein. Finde ich ein sehr
schönes Projekt. Und muss ich dazu
nur irgendwie Mitglied von irgendwas sein?
Du musst so einen VÖBB-Account haben, der ist wie gesagt
kostenlos für drei Monate, danach 10 Euro im Jahr.
Den trägst
und dann läuft das einfach.
Weil ich nämlich zum Beispiel überlegt hatte, ich habe jetzt dieses
Tablet, da könnte ich ja mal wieder Zeitungen
lesen. Zum Beispiel die Sächsische Zeitung.
Könnte man ja mal abonnieren. Was kostet das denn?
Viel zu viel. 30 Euro im Monat.
Dafür könntest du dir
einen Browser streamen.
Das ist eine geile Geschichte.
Sowas müssen wir machen.
Und darin musst du dann Stadia spielen oder sowas.
Wie heißt das?
Wie hieß das Ding?
Fuck, wie hieß das?
Mighty, Mighty App.
Mighty App. Okay, wer von euch da draußen,
Hand aufs Herz, wer von euch da draußen benutzt noch nicht
Mighty App?
MightyApp.com. Man versteht es
nicht so ganz von der Webseite her.
Die Intention von denen ist, die machen
Chrome schneller. Das steht ganz fest.
Make Chrome fast.
Und zwar? Mighty is a new browser
that lets you have more tabs
while taking 10x
less memory.
Das Problem ist halt, es klingt viel
versprechen, aber was die eigentlich machen.
Ist das da nicht sogar
minus 90 Memory
10xless. Ich verstehe solche Rechnungen
immer nicht. Ich glaube, die Aussage ist ein Zehntel.
Vielleicht sollten wir die Entspan fragen.
Build for Speed
Mighty streams your browser
from a powerful computer
in the cloud. Ah, das habe ich überlesen.
Unten steht nämlich nirgends vor.
It streams your browser. Und ich habe das
auf Twitter gesehen als Stadia für Chrome.
Essentiell ist es genau das.
Die stellen ja Hardware
in ihren Rechenzentren und
du als Person, die halt gar keinen Bock auf
in Form von Privatsphäre und sinnvoller Technik hast,
die streamt halt einfach deinen Browser komplett.
Das heißt, ich muss einfach mal meinen Browser aufmachen,
gehe auf Mighty App und habe dann da drin einen Browser,
wo ich eine Webseite aufhören kann.
Nee, die stellen dir schon eine eigene App.
Und natürlich ist das eine Electron-App,
weil du brauchst ja Chrome, um Chrome zu streamen.
Das heißt, anstatt sich mit Rendering beschäftigen zu müssen,
muss ich meinen Computer nur noch mit Videodecoding auseinandersetzen.
Mit sehr viel Videodecoding.
Stell dir mal vor, du schaust darüber Netflix oder so.
Das muss doch scheiße laufen.
Nö, das läuft wahrscheinlich super.
Ich meine, guck mal, bei Netflix kannst du dir
1080p...
Theoretisch kannst du es ja vorpuffern.
4K-Videos meine ich.
Ja, aber da ist es
gebuffert und vorher
schon gut enkutiert.
Ich meine, klar, du wirst natürlich auch in Realtime schauen.
Im Endeffekt ist es ja einfach bloß Screensharing.
Also ich kann aus Erfahrung sagen, dass Screensharing
sehr, sehr gut aussehen kann.
Wenn man es richtig macht.
Sicherlich. Bestimmt kann das ja auch ganz gut laufen.
Aber die Idee ist so bekloppt.
Diese Webseite ist vor allem, das sind einfach
sehr interaktive Webseiten, die sie dir zeigen, wo sie die
Geschwindigkeit angezogen haben, damit
es snappier wirkt. Das ist Figma mit
20 Leuten gleichzeitig.
Figma ist so ein Design-Prototyping-Tool,
was super weird, also das Tool
an sich ist nicht verkehrt. Ich finde es
angenehmer, native Sachen wie Sketch
zu benutzen, aber wir nutzen auf Arbeit auch
Figma. Es funktioniert. Das
weird an dem Tool ist, du kannst die Mauszeiger
aller anderen Leute, die das gleiche Dokument anschauen,
live sehen. Das heißt, du kannst nicht
mal die Webseite, du kannst
nicht mal deine Designs aufmachen,
ohne dass du dich beobachtet fühlst
und nachdenken musst darüber, wo du
deinen Mauszeiger gerade hinlegst, damit andere
Leute, der nicht im Weg ist oder so.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich sowas wie
Last of M nicht mehr nutzen kann, weil ich halt mich dann immer
nur, also gefühlt,
schaut mir die ganze Zeit jemand über die Schulter und hier ist das doch viel schlimmer.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt Last of M nur
geschaut, damit ich ein übelst geiles Profil
haben kann. Ich hab noch wie 10 Jahre gescrobbelt.
Ich hab letztens nochmal kurz gescrobbelt.
Direkt wieder dieses Gefühl gehabt,
wusste wieder, warum ich das nicht mehr genutzt hab.
Nee, das geht nicht. Aber bei
Erste Film habe ich mich immer gefragt, warum haben die nicht einfach
genau das gemacht, was Spotify heute macht,
einfach bloß schon zwölf Jahre vorher.
Hätten die Möglichkeiten potenziell dazu gehabt, das stimmt.
Nee, aber Mighty App kostet
30 Dollar im Monat.
Also nochmal, Mighty App ist einfach, ich habe eine App,
die wahrscheinlich eine Elektron-App ist, also auf Chrome basiert,
mit der ich dann über WebRTC oder über
wahrscheinlich nicht WebRTC, aber über
Die streamen ein langes GIF.
Ist das ein GIF?
Nein, Quatsch, aber das könnte man machen, da gibt es noch dieses Projekt.
Das hatten wir, glaube ich, so gemacht als Star.
Ja, ja, Endless GIF heißt das, glaube ich, oder sowas.
Äh, oh man.
Wir sind jetzt hier bei den Elektronen V und C klein,
stimmt schon. Und wie ernst ist das?
Scheint schon ernst zu sein.
Weißt du, was ich mir vorstelle, was das ist? Das ist nicht dafür da,
dass du das kaufst. Also es gibt bestimmt
ein paar Leute, die das kaufen.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich Leute, die das kaufen, aber
aber jemand, der sich die 30
Euro im Monat leisten kann, der kann
sich auch ein Computer leisten, wo Chrom normal läuft, oder?
Du kaufst dir einfach ein M1 Mac, dann hast du
seine Luft da auch nicht mehr. Oder ich meine,
wenn ihr Chrom zu lange seid, dann ist es halt Firefox.
Mein Gott.
aber ich glaube, das ist einfach hier, damit die Leute, die das gebaut haben
sagen können, guck mal, was wir drauf haben
wir machen ein Startup, damit wir irgendwo gekauft werden
die wollen einfach gekauft werden
die haben wahrscheinlich relativ viel Arbeit
in der Infrastruktur gesetzt
und die Tatsache, dass du damit einen Webbrowser
remote controlst und steuerst, ist bloß eine Demo
das ist nicht das eigentliche Produkt, das ist quasi das Aushängeschild
für deren technologische Infrastruktur
und die wollen gekauft werden, damit jemand
was anderes auf der Basis auf dieser Plattform
baut.
Zum Beispiel sowas wie Stadia.
Ich suche gerade die Webseite
whenwillgooglekillstadia.com
Oh, die gibt's gar nicht mehr.
Google hat die Seite gekillt?
Oh, nee.
Weil ich muss gerade denken,
ich kenne einen
absoluten Stadia-Verfechter.
Und ich meine,
wenn dein Play mit
MyTiApp ist irgendwie von Google
für Stadia gekauft zu werden oder so.
Natürlich auch geil.
WhenWillGoogleKillStadia.com war so eine schöne Seite,
wo Leute wetten konnten mit der Community,
wann Stadia gekillt wird. Und ich glaube,
die letzte Wette, als ich da geschaut habe,
habe ich das hier hingeschrieben
noch im Chat mit?
Nee, aber anscheinend nicht.
Ich meine, es war irgendwie August nächstes Jahr oder so.
Google doesn't want to kill Stadia, just Stadia as we know it.
Stadia gibt es doch auch erst seit einem Jahr, oder?
Ja, aber es ist für Google halt...
Du kennst doch den Google Graveyard.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe gehört, Angular wird jetzt
ausgefaced.
Aber das ist ja schon, also es ist schon länger
auf killedbygoogle.com.
Twitter. Ach nee.
Das kommt vom
Kontext her, sieht so was aus.
Angular seit Dezember 21.
Dead as the doorknob in 8 months.
AngularJS was a, achso,
it will be about 11 years old.
Schau nicht alt für ein Google-Projekt geworden.
Google Cardboard ist tot.
Was?
Tilt Brush.
Und die Seite ist halt endlos lang.
Naja, die haben halt einen ganz schönen Durchsatz.
Aber es ist halt dieses Google-Prinzip,
wir hauen was raus und wenn es halt
nicht eine Milliarde Dollar macht, dann war es halt
ein Test.
Und manche Sachen kleben halt wie
Gmail, Android,
keine Ahnung, andere Dinge.
Das Problem ist, dass die mit solchen
Aktionen dann häufig...
Ja, das ist halt genau das Ding.
Du stößt Kunden so richtig hart vorm Bug.
Nee, das meine ich nicht, aber
die haben halt eine unwahrscheinliche Marktmacht,
die machen dann manchmal was, was andere auch schon machen.
Ach, du meinst, die quetschen die anderen aus dem Markt raus?
Killen damit ihre Konkurrenz
und dann hören sie mit dem Produkt einfach wieder auf.
Das ist so wie die Leute, die Pebble kaufen,
um Pebble nicht mehr zu verkaufen.
Quasi.
Witzig. Das stimmt schon.
Es gibt auch häufig Geschichten von Firmen,
die von größeren Firmen gekauft werden
und dann einfach direkt geschlossen werden.
Ich weiß noch, ich bin immer noch salty wegen Google Reader damals.
Das habe ich gerne genutzt.
Das war der cooleste RSS-Reader zu der Zeit.
Da war Google noch cool zu der Zeit.
heutzutage würde ich Google Reader eh nicht mehr nutzen wollen
aber, also wegen Google
dahinter, aber Google Reader war schon
oh boah, war ich richtig pissig damals
ist gestorben
das habe ich also auch richtig aktiv genutzt
das ist als Tiny Tiny RSS so richtig groß geworden ist
TTRSS ist echt
ist so das, was Google Reader damals war, das stimmt schon
ja Leute, die behaupten
dass RSS tot sei, seitdem Google
wieder gestorben ist
als ob RSS tot sei
naja, ich muss gestehen, ich
lese nichts mehr
wirklich über RSS.
Was? Schon mein Feedreader, den ich ständig aufmache?
Ja? Also mein Feedreader
ist einfach Hacker News.
Also hier, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das
nicht sogar, für mich ist es so banal,
aber vielleicht ist das
ein Pickwert.
hckrnews.com
Du meinst die
akronomisierbar Themenquelle?
Genau, die akronomisierbar Themenquelle. Wir machen eine neue
Folge. Scrollen wir hier mal runter.
A Brief History of...
Das kannst du ja direkt nach Top sortieren.
A Brief History of Rust at Facebook.
Das hätte hier,
das hätte diese Folge sein können.
Ich glaube, die Ehren war nicht.
48 wird nicht veröffentlicht.
Doch, doch, doch, doch.
Okay, dann lass uns aber langsam beenden.
Ja, ja, war unterhaltsam bisher
auf jeden Fall. Aber ich glaube, wir kommen auch
rein. Das ist wirklich so ein Ding, dass man...
Also, liebe Zuhörer, wir leben noch,
wir haben vor, diesen Podcast
noch weiter zu machen.
Und wir haben auch vor, weiterhin
was mit Gästen zu machen. Wir haben die nächste Folge mit
einem Gast bereits geplant, da freue ich mich schon sehr drauf.
Und wenn sich
jemand bereit erklärt, mit uns über Rust
im Linux-Körnel zu reden,
vielleicht der Julian, oder vielleicht...
Lightweight topic, as always.
So ein richtig unvorbelastetes Thema.
Dann machen wir das sehr, sehr,
sehr, sehr gerne. Und ich würde sagen,
dann lassen wir heute mal das eine kurze
Folge sein, ne?
Damit du auch endlich von deinen
Füßen runter kannst. Du darfst dich auch gerne
auf meinen Schreibtisch schießen. Ich stehe auch gerne, ich wacke
mir so hin und her und verdrehe mir die Beine.
Das macht was aus.
Gut, das war
akronomisierbar Folge, naja, nennen wir
47 in Halb.
Nein, das war die 98, das ist normal.
Ey, die ist fast anderthalb Stunden
lang geworden.
Kommt gut durch.
Ich hoffe, ihr seid
durch die Pandemie gekommen bislang.
Und wir machen nächste Woche
nochmal eine Folge.
Hohe Versprechung.
Der nächste Podcast in deinem Podcatcher kommt in
3, 2, 1.
Das war eine Folge.
Wir sind aus dem Training gekommen.
Wir müssen ja üben.